اغلق بس الله
على الهوا مزبوط مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم
ربنا يسعد ليلتكم وكل ايامكم ان شاء الله
انا بس قبل ما استقبل اسئله حضراتكم
انا مش شايف اسئله
كان بس في صديق ارسل لي من الولايات
المتحده وقال لي انه ظروف التوقيت مش
مناسبه لكثير من الناس اللي موجودين واحنا
عندنا الحمد لله عدد مش قليل حوالي سبعه
تمانيه في الميه من اجمالي المتابعين من
الولايات المتحده فممكن اقتراح لهم ولكل
الاصدقاء اللي موجودين في دول هذا التوقيت
لا يناسبهم ممكن من المره الجايه
ابعتوا لي لما بعلن على اللايف يقولوا لي
انه هذه الاسئله التي يرغبون في ان
اتناولها لو كنت اعرف الاجابه طبعا ان شاء
الله ابدا بالاجابه عليها قبل اي حد يعني
شكرا جزيلا لحضرتكم
وعليكم السلام احمد هل هناك ده تشاد بيقول
هل هناك حقا ديمقراطيه الليبراليه تكدس
الثروات
بيدي نسبه قليله من الناس فمن المعروف ان
المال من يحكم السياسه في امريكا مثلا
تحكمها الطغم الماليه الكبرى مفهوم سؤالك
طبعا هو اخونا تشاد هي الفكره في انه
النظم نظم يعني الديمقراطيه
اشتراكيه الشكل المتطرف من الاشتراكيه
اللي هو
الشيوعيه متطرفه ويعلم السلبي يعني اللي
هي اقصى درجات الاشتراكيه يعني
الطريق الثالث تحط اي نظام تسميه يسار
يمين ولو بتحبوا نتكلم عليه وانا تحت
امركم كلها نظم على الورق نظم جيده لكن
نظم ديت نظم بيطبقها بشر والبشر هم البشر
طول الوقت هيكون حاول يطوع النظم ديت
علشان نصالحه
فبديهي انه صحيح الديمقراطيه نظام جيد جدا
ولو ما كانش نظام جيد جدا ما كانتش كل دول
العالم حتى اللي ما لهاش اي علاقه
بالديمقراطيه تتمسح فيه
ومع ذلك النظام بيجي يطبقوا ناس اللي
بيطبقوا الناس دول دايما الفئه القويه هي
اللي هتحاول تطوعه بحيث ان هي تستفيد منه
فالعيب مش في الديمقراطيه ولا في
الاشتراكيه ولا في النظم اللي بتحمل اسامي
دينيه او غيره ولكن في طبيعه البشر
ويعني هذه طبيعه الانسان يعني
حازم احمد مساء القشطه مساء القشطه
مستنيين فيديو قناه نعرف
مش عارف نعرف اذا او نعرف ابا يمكن مش
مكتمل يوسف ميلاد
على فكره بمناسبه السؤال الاولاني هو لسه
الكلام بيجي بذهني سؤال اتشات بس انا خايف
الحلقه كلها تروح عليه انت لما تقرا
الكلام اللي كتبه ماركس تحسه انه راجل
بيتكلم في عالم عظيم جدا عالم من العداله
المطلقه لما تشوف الجماعه بتوع اليمين
اليمين عندنا مرتبط بان هم ناس متطرفين
وعاوزين الاثريه بيتكلموا عن عداله
اجتماعيه انا عاوز اشجع الاثرياء علشان
يخلقوا فرص للفقراء
كلام على الورق انا اسف ان انا رجعت تاني
هل محاوله الولايات المتحده العوده الى
الاتفاق مع ايران هي محاوله لتحيد ايران
في الحرب الاوكرانيه عن طريق سياسه العصا
والجزره هو حتى الان
اخونا اونر الولايات المتحده لم تعلن عن
رغبتها الجاده في العوده ولا معرفش حتى
النظريه للعوده للاتفاق النووي
اخر كلام كان على لسان الولايات المتحده
على لسان الرئيس الامريكي كان بيحدث
السيده واظنها من اصل ايراني من حوالي
ثلاث او اربع شهور وقال لها
الكاميرات كلها كانت سمعاه ان الاتفاق مات
وحتى اذا لم يقل فالاتفاق قد مات هم
مشكلتهم انه
الاتفاق ولا قادرين يجدوا حلا لما يسمى
بالمساله الايرانيه او الازمه الايرانيه
اما حكايه ان يحيدوها فده كان التصور في
الاول يعني لما جاب رئيس بايدن
كان عدد من منظري السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه ودول فريق كبير توصل لاكثر من
2000 خبير بيقدم استشاره للرئيس الامريكي
في ملفات المختلفه وفي ناس بتساعد ممكن
الالفين دول
كان عندهم تصور عظيم جدا وجودتو بيترو زي
ما بيقولوا عظيم لدرجه انه صعب يتحقق
الفكره انه الخطر الاساسي جاي من الصين بس
ما نقدرش نقاتل الصين او نضغط عليها الا
اذا حيدنا المشكله الايرانيه دي دوله من
دول العالم الثالث في نهايه المطاف ما فيش
داعي ان هي تجرنا لحرب يعني تشغلنا عن
الهدف الكبير ونحاول ان احنا نسترضي او
نهدئ الاوضاع مع روسيا ومركز على الصين
لكن بعد سنتين اكتشف الرئيس الامريكي انه
هو الحرب مشتعله مع الصين
ومشتعله مع الروس اكثر مما تتخيل تخيل اي
حد من هؤلاء الخبراء وانه احتمال يتورط في
حرب ثالثه مع ايران وان الثلاثه دول مع
بعض رغم ما بينهم من تناقضات
اقرب الى بعضهم البعض اكثر من اي وقت مضى
زيرو للسياسه الخارجيه
للرئيس بايدن حتى هذه اللحظه
الحرب العالميه ستارت ده اخونا من
كاليفورنيا والله هو طبعا
يعني دايما نقطه يعني
الناس بتحب الحرب قوي وبتخاف منها قوي
الحرب العالميه حاجه مرعبه يعني انت الدول
الكبيره لما تبتدي تحارب
يعني على راي الكلمه المشهوره اينشتاين
بيقولوا له الحرب
القادمه تحارب ازاي فقال لهم انا ما اعرفش
تحارب ازاي او لانه اذا استخدم السلاح
النووي يعني في حرب عالميه ثالثه في
الغالب يعني هتبقى الادوات اللي هتيجي بعد
هذا اللقاء هي العصيه بقى والحاجات
البدائيه جدا لانه الحرب النوويه لم تبقي
ولا انتظر وصعب السيطره ان الدول دي تحارب
ويبقى في دول منها معرضه للخساره زي وضع
روسيا كده ولا تلجا للسلاح النووي اذا
طالت الحرب على العموم اجابه سؤال حضرتك
الاجابه انه للاسف الشديد اصبح الحديث عن
الحرب العالميه الثالثه زي ما قلنا كتير
امر وارد جدا جدا اكثر مما يتخيل الكثيرون
اتمنى ما يحصلش طبعا واضيف لحضرتك بعد
تاريخي ان كتير من الحروب اللي هبه
التاريخ وبنتكلم عنها الحرب العالميه
الاولى والحرب العالميه الثانيه
وحروب اقليميه هنا زي الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه كتير جدا الحروب دي العالم ما
ادركش انه دخل فيها ايه اللي بعد ما
اندلعت يعني بدات باحداث صغيره بدات على
انطاق صغير كل طرف معتقد انه عنده القدره
على السيطره عليها واصبحت فيما بعد
التاريخ بيكتبها كانه الباقيين عارفين ان
هم داخلين الحرب العالميه الاولى ما كانش
عارفين
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ما كانش عارفين
ونقطه انطلاق الحرب عاده
بتبدا الشراره تبدا السبب يبدا ويبتدي
يختمر لشهور وربما عده سنوات عشان يؤدي
السلسله من التفاعلات تؤدي للحدث الكبير
اخشى ان يكون الشراره انطلقت وان الاحداث
بتتسارع
والناس ذاهبين الى الصراع الكبير وهم نيام
بالمناسبه في كتاب جميل جدا اسمه
سليب بوكينج انتم ويرلدور
او الذهاب نوما منوما الى الحرب العالميه
الاولى
كتاب جميل لو دورت عليه يحكي لك القصه دي
بتاع الحرب العالميه الاولى وازاي كتير من
القوه دخلتها وهي لا تعلم انها مقبله على
30 سنه من الصراع سنوات الحرب العالميه
الاولى الاربع سنين ثم ما بين الحربين ثم
الحرب العالميه الثانيه اللي كانت نتيجه
للحرب العالميه الاولى
استاذ سيد ممكن البرنامج يكون له بودكاست
والله
والسؤال صديقي مندو اللي هو خبير في هذه
الامور اعرف الفرق بس يعني انا لما بشوف
انا يعني الشباب بيوروني كده بودكاستو
وعندي حد من اولادي ابني الكبير مهم جدا
بالبودكاست اللي هي باللغه الانجليزيه
يعني
انا شايف ان انا بعمل حاجه قريبه منها
يعني الى حد ما بس مش عارف بودكاست يعني
ان انا احط دي على ودني انا مش عارف انا
انا مش بسخر والله نفسي اعرف لانه انا انا
بعتقد ان الماده ديت هي قريبه للي انا
حابه اقدمه سواء في شكل حوارات سواء في
شكل مونولوج وطويل وبنتكلم زي اللي انا
بعمله دلوقتي بس انا حاسس ان الفرق في
الشكل فلو ان في فرق جوهري يا ريت استفيد
واتعلم منك
ونقشه مع ماندو ونشوف ممكن نعمله ازاي
السلام عليكم سيد جبيل متابعك من الاردن
من سنين ربنا يخليك حقا عليك حقنا عليك
تغطي الاردن سياسيا بشكل اكبر حاضر اخونا
حاضر اخونا ايهم حاضر بكل سرور
سؤال تشاد كانت جاوب تشاد عن السؤال تاني
المعروف تاني حاضر السلام عليكم انت
وعدتني بحق عن اقتصاد فيتنام واسباب
فيتنام واسباب نهضتها
انا يعني ده انا لو عملت كده يبقى انا انا
مش فاكر خالص ان انا اتكلمت على اقتصاد
فيتنام بس لكن هقول لك على حاجه يعني طبعا
انا هديك اجابه سريعه
انا مش خبير يعني في الشان الفيتنامي ولكن
انت عارف ان فيتنام طبعا كانت ضحيه للصراع
القوه الكبرى اثناء الحرب البارده صراع
الصين والاتحاد السوفيتي والولايات
المتحده وكانت الفكره الحرب فيتنام
الشهيره كانت فكره الولايات المتحده كانت
الفكره فين ان احنا عندنا قوه مناصره
في الشمال للقوى الشرقيه يعني تحدي
السوفيتي والصين والجنوب كان مناصر
للولايات المتحده وكانت الولايات المتحده
خايفه ان هي تسيب منطقه فيتنام يعني كده
ليه التغول
الشيوعيه ممثله او مدعومه من الاتحاد
السوفيتي والصين وبالتالي يضغط شمال على
الجنوب وتنتقل الشيوعيه من فيتنام الى دول
اخرى فابتدت الحرب ودي برضه مثال على
الحرب اللي بتبدا وما حدش عارفها استمرت
سنين سرا الى انفجرت وسببت خسائر مهوله
لكل الاطراف وطبعا منها القوه الكبيره
العين الولايات المتحده
بعد سنين فيتنام
كانت واحده من الدول اللي الولايات
المتحده ارادت ان هي توثق علاقتها بيها
على اساس ان هي تكون نموذج جاذب لدوله
موجوده في جوار خصوم الولايات المتحده
اللي هي طبعا الصين بالدرجه الاولى وروسيا
بالدرجه الثانيه ويبقى نموذج ناجح كانها
بتزرع شوكه فيه يعني خسوره هؤلاء مش هي
الدوله الوحيده يعني في دول منها مثلا
[موسيقى]
السنغافوره انه الولايات المتحده تدعمها
بقوه مش حبا في سنغافوره ولا حاجه ولكن
لانه ده يبقى نموذج للنجاح في منطقه تخشى
الولايات المتحده انه يسيطر عليها النموذج
الصيني او النموذج الروسي ونتكلم ان شاء
الله يعني فيتنام هو اقتراح جميل بس انا
سامحني انا مش فاكر هذا الوعد هينضم الى
مجموعه كثيره من الوعود المؤجله فيتنام
هل انتهى دور انجلترا كدوله عظمى نعم قولا
واحدا سي السيد هل ممكن الاسعار والغلاء
في مصر يقل ليس في الامد القريب يا صديقي
الغلا مرتفع لانه الغلا مرتفع اولا في مصر
وفي غير مصر لكن طبعا الغلبه يزيد في
الدول اللي ظرفها اقتصاديه اقل
والاخبار اللي احنا كنا فرحانين بها واحنا
عملنا حلقه
اعتمادا على تقارير الفيدرالي الامريكي
واعتمادا على كل بيوت الخبره من حوالي
شهرين تلاته انه في منحنى هيبقى بطيء
لفائده الامريكيه ولكن
فجاه وجدنا ان الفيدراليه الامريكي بيقول
انا مش قادر اسيطر على التضخم كما كنت
اتوقع
وعليه فالمتوقع لسه كان بيقول الكلام ده
في شهاده قدام الكونجرس انه قد نضطر الى
زياره معدلات الفائده مره اخرى يزيد
معدلات الفائده يعني حاجتين اول حاجه انه
الاموال الاجنبيه اللي موجوده عندك اللي
انت بتعتمد عليها في انها تمول لك الديون
بديون هتهرب هتروح امريكا الفائده هياخد
فايده هناك مضمونه ليه يحطها في بلد من
دول العالم الثالث ممكن تتعثر اثنين ان
الدول دي خصوصا مع زينه اسعار كل السلع
اربع وخمس اضعاف ترى وقمحه كل حاجه وزيوت
وكل شيء هتجد علشان تشتري ده محتاجه تقترض
علشان تقترض هتقترض بفايده امريكا هترفع
الفايده كده معناه ان احنا بنتكلم على
حوالي 6%
امريكا تقترب بسته في الميه لكن مصر
الاردن المغرب هيقترضوا ب 12% وهي بيقترض
دلوقتي في حدود باكتر من 11% يبقى لو زادت
الفائده هتزيد نسبه مهوله جدا وعليه فمن
غير المتوقع انه الاسعار تقل الدول
الناميه كلها وليست مصر عندهم خصيتين واحد
ان ما عندهمش اكتفاء ذاتي من سلع رئيسيه
كل الدول بتستورد بس ان انت تستورد
اسقاطش ويسكي مثلا حد مرفه في روسيا عاوز
يشتري والله الويسكل اسكتلندي عاوز يشتري
سيجار كوبي ماشي يشتري سلع
تكنولوجيه ماشي انما بتكلم على السلع
الرئيسيه اكل وشرب وعلاج الدول الناميه ما
عندهاش اكتفاء معقول من السلعه الرئيسيه
دي وعشان كده حتى لما هي بتبطل السلع
الرفاهيه برضو عندها مشكله لان هي عاوزه
تستورد سلعه رئيسيه اثنين
انه هي
بتعتمد على الديون طبعا اكتر من غيرها ما
عندهاش هي الدولار تطبعه ولا عندها يورو
تطبعه عندها عمله محليه ليست محل ثقه احد
لما بتزيد الفائده في الولايات المتحده في
الازمات معناها ان هي بقت عندها مشكله
مضاعفه السلعه الاساسيه زي ما هو حاصل
الان بخمس اضعافها قبل اندلاع الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وقبل اندلاع ازمه
كورونا اثنين انه تكلفه الدين تضاعفت
مرتين وتلاته بسبب رفع اسعار الفائده في
امريكا لو فكرتي مش واضحه استاذنك قل لي
وانا اوضح مره تانيه
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله يا جيمس هل
انتهى يا ريت راي حضرتك في اللقاءات
العربيه مع بشار الاسد السبب السبب واضح
هو في
سوريا بلد بقسمتها بتبحث عن حل في تسوق في
تصورات للحل في تصور يقول والله احنا لو
ادخلنا بشار الاسد في زي ما بيقولوا كده
الحضن العربي البيت العربي
وابتدينا نتعامل معه ونوفر له ما يريد من
مساعدات هتقل حاجته الى ايران
وبالنسبه للدول العربيه وايران تمثل الخصم
الرئيسي لبعض الدول العربيه
وبالتالي بيقولوا عاوزين ويجي
وفي تصور تاني انه لا امل من اقناع بشار
الاسد لانه بشار الاسد وقبله حافظ الاسد
من سنه 79 عندهم علاقات وثيقه من ايران
واذا اراد ان يتخلى عن ايران ايران لم
تسمح له وعليه فلازم نسقطه ونضغط عليه
فالتيارين دول مشتعلين ما تنساش ان منهم
التيار التاني ومثلا بتقود المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بتتوافق في هذا الكلام
مع دوله زي الولايات المتحده اللي هي حتى
الان يعني غير راغبه في فتح الباب امام
عوده بشار الاسد
للدول العربيه يعني
مرحبا بالمومياء الله يخليك ويخلي حضرتك
شكرا جزيلا تحياتي ومحبتي ده انت بتقول
وانا بقول لك تحياتي ومحبتي ليك الاسم شعر
حضرتك كاتب لماذا العديد من العرب يؤمنون
بنظريه المؤامره
ما دين ايران ما بين ايران واسرائيل هل
قتلت
الجزيره لها دور في هل قتلت الجزيره لها
دور في الترويج لذلك وما رايك بقناه
الجزيره بشكل عام تحياتي شوف الايمان
بنظريه المؤامره موجود في الدول العربيه
وانا كنت فاكر احنا بس كعرب لكن موجود
بشراسه في دول اخرى روسيا
حدث ولا حرج ايران حدث ولا حرج تركيا حدث
ولا حرج
ودي لها قصه طويله انما يعني يعني اسباب
الايمان بنظريه المؤامره وتعريف لنظريه
المؤامره هو وجود مخاوف كبيره من اشياء لا
يوجد عليها دلائل يعني ان انت تخاف من
حاجه مخيفه عليها دليل اوكيه انما تخاف من
حاجه ما لهاش اصل ما فيش دليل عليه هي دي
هي دي نظريه المؤامره
اما فيما يتعلق بايران واسرائيل انا شخصيا
مندهش طبعا في اسباب للناس اللي بيؤمنوا
بالقصه ديت واللي بيؤمنوا به انه ايران
واسرائيل دول الحبايب عندهم خلط بين
مجموعه من الامور
التاريخ والحاضر مثلا فانه كانت ايران
صديقه لاسرائيل في فتره من الفترات هذا
صحيح لكنها لم تعد كذلك فهو في خلط يقول
لك ما هم كانوا بيتعاملوا وكانوا اصدقاء
ايوه ماشي ايام الشاي يقول لك لا مش ايام
الشام وكمان اثناء الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه ايوه ماشي ما هو اثناء الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه كان
يعني العمليه بقت ايران بتبحث عن اي حد
يساعدها اللي كان مستعد يساعدها عدد محدود
منهم اسرائيل نكايه في صدام حسين فمش
حبايب احنا جمعنا عدو مشترك صدام حسين
نفسه بعد الحرب اللي هو قضى تمن سنين لما
حب يحمي طيرانه ابتدى يوثق علاقته مع
ايران وكانت الدماء لم تنشف بعد يعني
وارسل اظن 100 طائره لم يعودوا من ساعتها
والتاريخ ومصير المئه الطائره دول عليهم
علامه استفهام والله
بيخلطوا ما بين
يعني امور تانيه انه على سبيل المثال يخلط
ما بين انه مثلا
دعم الولايات المتحده وفرنسا للخوماني
ايوه ده صحيح وكان موجود في فرنسا لكن
عودته دعمه شيء والسيطره عليه وتصرفاته
لاحقا شيء تاني يعني خلط بين مجموعه من
الامور المؤكد المؤكد ان انت عشان تبحث عن
دليل ان هم اصدقاء مساله انا بعتقد ان هي
عبثيه فيما انه العداء واضح كون او يخلطوا
بالامور تانيه ان اسرائيل وامريكا
بيبالغوا في الخطر الايراني علشان مش عارف
ايه يعني يعتزوا العرب يجوز بس هي ظل
الايران واسرائيل لا يوجد منطق يقول ان هم
اصدقاء وحبايب لا يمكن ابدا تكون محبه مع
هذا القدر من العقوبات المهوله الواقعه
على البلد وعلى الشعب الى اخره يعني
قناه الجزيره قناه جزء من الاعلام العربي
اللي موجود
عندها مزايا وعندها عيوب لكن لما تيجي تضع
الاطار كله هتجد انه انا مش للاسف يعني ما
بتابعهاش من حوالي سنتين مش لانه انا مش
عاوز اتابعها ولا حاجه ولكن لانه في مصر
لاسباب يعني انا يمكن من ايام مكاتب مشكله
ما قدرتش تاني استقبلها بسهوله طبعا ممكن
ابحث وابذل جهد واجيبها بس ده ما حصلش
يعني انما
هي قناه فيها مزايا وفيها عيوب ومن ضمن
عيوبها طبعا انها مسيسه الى حد كبير جدا
جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا اللي
يغفر لها ده او يخفف من حدتها انها لا
تختلف عن الاعلام السعودي ولا الاعلام
المصري ولا الاعلام الجزائري ولا الاعلام
المغربي لكن الجزائر ان هي بتبدو ان هي بس
هي مش حياديه هي عندها اجنده بتتوافق
تماما مع مصالح القائمين عليها وبتحاول
تعملها احيانا بشكل مهني بينطلي على الناس
واحيانا تاني طبعا بتبقى العمليه مفضوحه
جدا
وعندها ميزات الميزات ديت ان عندهم ناس
مهنيين كويسين جدا عندهم قدره ان يسبقوا
في الحدث في تغطيته عندهم قدره على
استضافه ضيوف هائلين طبعا ده بيساعدهم في
المساله ديت ان عندهم دايره واسعه من
المحرمات اللي موجوده في القنوات الاخرى
مرفوعه عندهم
في قنوات كبيره ممنوع ممنوع ممنوع لانه
السياسه الخارجيه للبلد اللي مسيطره عليها
شايفه ان دي محاذير قطر فتحه المحاذير دي
كتير بتتكلم كتير كتير كتير في موضوعات
دول تانيه تخاف تتكلم فيها وطبعا
الامكانيات الماليه
هل يؤدي الخلاف بين حماتي والبرهان في حرب
اهليه ارجوك لا يعني اتمنى لا ان شاء الله
ما ياديش الى هذا يعني هم عايشين في هذا
الخلاف واتمنى انه يقدروا يحتوه
اللي هم يعني العسكريين اللي موجودين
يعني بيتهيالي لا هم عندهم القدره على فتح
حرب اهليه
ومعتقدش يعني ان المساله توصل لحرب اهليه
ولا دول العالم الاخرى ممكن تتحمل اندلع
حرب اهليه تاني فضلا عن اهل السودان
امنيات يعني لكن علمنا تاريخ السودان انها
بتخرج من حفره تقع للاسف في اخرى لماذا
تلجا بعض الدول العربيه غير البتروليه الى
رفع مستوى الجمارك بشكل مبالغ فيه
ما هو لما بيكون انت ما عندكش موارد
الطبيعي ان لو انت عندك اقتصاد قوي فانت
مش هتفكر كثير في رفع اسعار الضرائب بشكل
يشل المنتج ولا في رفع اسعار الجمارك لانك
انت محتاج واردات اساسيه
سواء انتاجيه او استهلاكيه ومحتاج تصدر
والناس هتعاملك بالمثل يعني بس لو انت ما
عندكش موارد
وظروفك الاقتصاديه صعبه اول حاجه بتفكر
فيها انك تزود الحصيله الضرائب سواء في
اشكال ضريبه اللي هي بتدفعها باشكالها
المختلفه او في شكل الرسوم على الخدمات
الحكوميه او في شكل رسوم على الجمارك اللي
هي شكل من اشكال الضرائب يعني
فهي نوع من قله الحيله محاوله
للحق ضرر بنفسك لانك انت لما بتزود
الجمارك بتضر نفسك الناس مش هتبقى تستورد
الناس مش هتصدر الناس كده يعني لكن بتقول
انا اوقع بنفسي هذا الضرر في مقابل اللي
انا احل مشكلتي العاجله جدا وهي نقص
السيوله
الوضع الاقتصادي الصعب
السلام عليكم هل في رايك ستقوم اسرائيل
بشن حرب على ايران هذا هو السؤال ده ماهر
الاسئله قفزت ماشيه معايا بطيئه وبعدين
انت كنت حابس الاسئله ماندو
انا عاوزه اقول لكم انا عاوز اقول لك على
حاجه حصلت مشكله في الصوت صحيح انا عاوز
اعتذر لكم في الحلقه الاخيره اللي هي
والله كانت حلقه جيده عن الارجنتين فحصل
ان المايك بتاعي انا تعطل
يعني كده فجاه فما انتبهناش
فانا بعتذر لكم اولا انما من التعليقات
اللطيفه ان حد قال النايك اتقطع عن سيد
جبيل وماندو هو السبب لانه سيد قال عليه
قبل كده عامله مزدوج ما يعرفوش في الموضوع
اسف حاجات جلد بسرعه ارجع ثاني
وانا كنت قريت سؤال وبعدين طار بس هرجع له
يعني
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ده عبد الصمد
عبد الصمد الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه هي
حرب استنزاف ومعركه ضخمه هي معركه تكسير
عظام ليس الا
الحرب ستطول اؤيدك صديقي هل دائما من يكتب
التاريخ هو المنتصر طبعا يعني طبعا انت
سمعت ان مثلا يعني هتلر كتب كتب التاريخ
ما هو راجل انتحر واتهزم واللي ما قتلش
نفسه قتلوه ومن لم يقتلوه سجنوه فيعني
حكموه
ارجوك ان تشرح الوديعه لماذا تقوم دوله
بمنح وديعه لدوله اخرى ماذا تستفيد
ليس ماليا فقط وانما سياسيا شكرا لك اخوك
زايد يا اخونا زايد المساله الرسيطه جدا
لما تيجي مثلا الامارات او قطر او المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تضع وديعه في البنك
المركزي
تركيا او مصر او المغرب او غيره رقم واحد
الوديعه هي وديعه انا احط خمسه مليار
دولار فانا هاخد عليها زي مثلا نسبه متفق
عليها نصرف المئه واحد في المئه في نسبه
ممكن تبقى النسبه اللي هي نسبه السوق ممكن
تكون اقل شويه اذا كانت دعم مالي فهي
بتحصل على عائد حتى لو قليل اثنين
ان انا لما اجي دوله زي مصر المساله
الاخيره بتاع
تركيا انه كذا دوله خليجيه او دعت اموال
هي بيكون نوع من الدبلوماسيه ويعني انا
بقى امون عليك انا بقول لك انا ايباليو
اوت انا بوديعه انا اربع عليها او لا اخسر
وفي نفس الوقت انا بسجل عندك نقطه بقول لك
والله انا قدمت السبت انتظر الاحد فانا
النهارده قدمت السبت وساعدت
الاتراك في تجاوز عثرتهم وانتظر منهم واحد
اتنين تلاته اربعه علاقات طيبه بتاخد شكل
كتير جدا ان انا احسن العلاقه يعني ده
معناها ان انا اامن اذاهم واطلب رضاهم
واستفيد من مزاياهم كثير على المستوى
التجاري والعسكري والسياسي والدبلوماسي
وهكذا فزي ما انت بالضبط صديقك احتاج
اقرضته انت بتسترد قردك تاني دي اول حاجه
وطبعا لو كانت غير ان هم طبعا مش بس
بيستردوا القرض في الغرب بياخدوا فايده
كمان بيبقى يعني هو مدين لك هيردها لك
مش قصدي على الفلوس يعني هيردها لك في شكل
دعم تاني ومساعدات الى اخره
يعني انت لما حصل انه في سنوات القطيعه ما
بين قطر وما بين الدول العربيه الاربعه
كانت قطر اقرضت وساعدت
التركيه عده مرات خصوصا بعد محاوله
الانقلاب في يولو 2016 وبعد تراجع وتدهور
الاقتصاد التركي لاسباب متعدده اول ما قطر
وقعت في مشكله مع جيرانها كان
الاتراك اول من صارعوا على كل المستويات
دعم سياسي دعم اقتصادي كل اللي انتم مش
قادرين تستوردوه عن طريق السعوديه او مصر
بتاع هبعته لكم انا بالطيران دعم على طول
امني ان انا ارسل قوات عسكريه تؤمن
القطر هناك والاسره الحاكمه ابعت ادرب
اعمل قاعده عسكريه هناك كنوع من التامين
ان انا في ظهركم وده كان سبب مباشر يعني
اخونا يا ريت تكتبه اساميكم بالعربي اكون
شاكر لكم اجد صعوبه في قراءه الاسامي
العربي باللغه الانجليزيه حضرتك تقدم
بودكاست لكن ناقص مايكروفون احترافي
لتحسين الصوت يبقى يبقى هو البودكاست هو
هو بس احنا عندنا على فكره اهو بس ماندو
مش عاوز يديهولي
عندنا والله بس تفتكر هو اخونا بس هو
الصوت هو المشكله هو المايك يعني كل سنه
وحضرتك طيب ربنا يخليك ويسعدك محمد فتحي
اسلام احمد السلام عليكم عليكم السلام
ماذا لو انتهت الحرب في اليمن وحكم الحوثي
تبقى بصراحه مشكله لليمن ومشكله ليه غير
اليمن عوافر الاحترام للحوثيين وليا
اصدقاء يعني بيتواصلوا معي يعني طبعا
حماسهم للحوثيين قال عن الاول في الاخر
ماذا يستطيع الحوثين ان يقدموه لاهل اليمن
الاول احنا بنتكلم على جماعه
عندها قناه دينيه
الاساس في شرعيتها هو النسب للرسول عليه
الصلاه والسلام جيد ده كل الاحترام لكن
هذا ليس ده سبب ان انت الناس توبرك تقدرك
اذا كان سلوكك اذا كان سلوكك مش بمجرد
نسبك
يعني يؤهلك الى ذلك لكن ليس ده مش اساس
للشرعيه والا هنلاقي ان احنا بنتكلم على
شكل مختلف تماما تماما لا علاقه له انا مش
عاوز اناقشه ده ما لوش علاقه بالدين يعني
انه مش كونك انت من احنا كده بنتكلم على
نظام حكم قائم على النسب النسب لعائله
الرسول وهنخش في قصه تانيه خالص خالص
مختلفه تماما وهنلاقي عندنا مئات الاسر
اللي في كل دول العالم اللي بتقدم ورق
وتقول انا من انساب الرسول وانا عاوزه
احكم
على المستوى
الاقتصادي على المستوى السياسي ماذا ماذا
لدى الحوثيين يؤهلهم للحكم بخلاف تقدير
بعض الناس لهم باختلاف امتلاك السلاح اللي
كان اقوى من الخصومهم
بخلاف
استثمارهم الجيد لفشل الحكومات السابقه
خلاف ذلك ماذا لديهم زي طالبان ماذا لدى
طالبان غير قدره على الحرب الى ما لا
نهايه لكن لما يجوا للحكم بقى ماذا فعل
طالبان منذ ان تركهم الامريكان
في سبتمبر 2021
لماذا لا تتحدث عن مصائب التي تلحق ببلدك
ما سر
ما اعرفش ما سر وتتدخل في شؤون الشعوب
والاقوال في الاخرى يا اخونا انا مش بتدخل
انا انا يعني انا مجرد صحفي اتدخل ديت
يعني انا ادبر انقلابات يعني انا ازعل
تعيين حكام انا مجرد صحفي والصحفي اذا كان
مصري اذا كان مغربي اذا كان امريكي اذا
كان نيجيري هو شغلانته انه بيتابع الشان
العالمي وبيساعد الناس في رؤيته انا اكل
عيشي من 30 سنه ان انا اتابع اللي بيقرا
فيه العالم وبعد ما اتابعه وافهمه واستعين
بمن يعني يلقي الضوء انا كصحفي وظيفتي ان
انا اقول اللي بيجري في نيجيريا هكذا بعد
ما اكون قريت وتابعته وسافرت وشفته
واستقلت الناس ونقلت اللي بيحصل ولما بحصل
لما بعمل ده انا بحصل على اجر مقابل عملك
صحفي فيها ده ما بيعتبرش تدخل والا كانت
اغلقت كل وسائل الاعلام وكل شيء
فيعني بعدين ايه مصائب بلدي ما احنا يعني
البلد مصر عندها مشاكل انا بتكلم عليها
وبتكلم عن المشاكل اللي اعرفها في الاردن
وفي امريكا وفي روسيا
يعني انا مشكلتي معك ان انا مصري يعني
مساء الخير مساء اهلا وسهلا
السلام عليكم ما هو بصير افغانستان في ظل
حكم طالبنا انا لسه قايل انا قلت انا قلت
من فتره يا استاذ محمد جمال انه النوعيه
اللي هي قايمه على اللي هي وده مش بس لان
هم مسلمين متدينين يعني او ان هم عاوزين
نفس الكلام كان ان انت عاوز تحكم بس لانك
انت عاوز ترفع مبادئ شيوعيه وخلاص انت
عاوز تحكم دوله على اي اساس عقائدي او
يعني بيسموها دوجما يعني
لا ده ده يعني انا كان تقديري انه طالبين
ليس لديها ما تقدمه لافغانستان
ومع يعني القصه اللي احنا كنا بنقولها
دايما الحلقه اللي انا اتكلمت عنها كتير
ولا تسمح الظروف بسبب تتابع الاحداث انه
المسلمين
من ضمن اخفاقتهم الكبيره انه تحدثوا كثيرا
عن امنيتهم في ان تحكموا الشريعه وان يكون
هناك نظام حكم اسلامي لكن لم ينجح
المسلمون على مدار سنين طويله اللي هم
بيقولوا كده يعني ان هم يقدموا نظاما
متميزا عن غيره من النظم يعني ما حدش نجح
انه يطلع لنا يقول لنا ده اقتصاد اسلامي
طبقوه ده نظام حكم يختلف عن اي نظام اخر
حكم به بقى الفرس ولا الرومان ولا مش عارف
مين من الحضارات الوسطى والقديمه
والحضارات الحديثه اذا انت حكمت به الناس
بيعرفوا على طول انك مسلم مفيش الكلام ده
واللي مختلف معايا يفتح معي الحديث
ونتناقش ما هو الذي اتى به علماء المسلمين
كنظام حكم يتم تطبيقه عمليا على الارض
يختلف عن انظمه اخرى لا يوجد
على الاقل حتى الان اذا كان في حد عنده
قدره يجتهد ويبذل مجهود
ويصيغ نظام اقتصاد مثلا اسلامي واضح
الملامح يمكن تطبيقه يختلف عن النظام
الراسماليه والنظام الاشتراكي وغيرهم يا
ريت يقول لنا هو فين
استاذ سيد يعطيك العافيه على ساعه صدرك هل
تتفق بانه اذا تقدمت وتطورت جميع الدول
العربيه اقتصاديا وعسكريا سيؤدي ذلك
لسهوله التوحد وفي تكتل عسكري واقتصادي
لخم والله يا اخونا انا برضو عندي صعوبه
في نطق الاسامي اللي هي ماي ونوش ومايونها
انا اسف مش عارف انطق الاسم لكن
يعني طبعا انت بتفترض حاجه هايبو فاتيكا
الافتراضيه اذا تقدمت الدول العربيه
عسكريا
واقتصاديا
ممكن حاجات كتيره تحصل لكن
يعني
نركز الاول على الجانب الاول من الامنيه
ثم نتحدث بقى على فكره التحالفات لانه
بصراحه الجزء الاول حتى الان للاسف بعيد
شويه احنا بعيد عن هذا لكن ما فيش ما يمنع
نفترض انه الدول دول الخليج كتله مثلا او
المغرب دول المغرب العربي قدرت ان هي
تتجاوز خلافات تقدمت اولا
تجاوزت خلافتها اثنين ثلاثه بقى فيه ثقه
متبادله ايه اللي يمنع ان احنا نبقى كتله
تبقى كتله اقتصاديه كتله كتله جمركيه
واحده ما الذي يمنع بس ده مش مش وارد في
الامد القريب ولا الامد المتوسط يعني
من فضلك هل عندك تصور لنهايه الازمه
اليمنيه
[موسيقى]
عندي تصور لنهايه الاسئله الايمانيه ان هي
تبقى موجوده صراع منخفض الحده يعني يعني
الحوثيين اصبح واضح جدا بعد كل السنوات
ديت من 2015 ادركوا حدود قدراتهم ان هم مش
هيقدروا يخرجوا من مناطق نفوذهم الى كامل
اليمن واضح جدا انه القوى اللي موجوده على
تنوعها في باقي الدول منطقه اليمن يعني
اللي ممكن نسميه باليمن الجنوبي ارادوا
بالوضع الراهن
وبيطوله يعني في بيكسب وقت لكن في الوقت
الحالي هم غير قادرين على حسم الصراع
والمشكله الاكبر انه مش هتبقى قدرتهم على
ويبدو ان كمان دول خارجيه مش يبدو يعني
متاكد ان دول خارجيه ترى ان الوضع الراهن
انسب لها لان ما عندهاش قدره على تغيير
موازين القوه في الداخل
الخوف كل الخوف انه القوى الاخرى اللي هي
متنوعه ضد الحوثي يعني تبدا الصراعات تدب
بينها لان في اسباب جوهريه تخليها
انها تختلف فيما بينها لا يجمعهم الى
الخلاف مع الحوثي
وبالتالي اذا هم سلموا بسيطره الحوثي على
الشمال او اذا تغلبوا على الحوث لاي سبب
من الاسباب فلا يبدو ان هناك اي
مؤشرات تقول ان اليمن سوف يكون مستقرا في
ظل الخلافات الكبيره بين القوى المتحالفه
ضد الحوثي الحل الوحيد الامنيه مش التوقع
ان تتحل المشكله مع ايران اولا وتهدا
المسائل مع ايران وتبتدي القوى اللي هي
اصحاب المصالح الرئيسيه دول الخليج
مصر طبعا السودان
ايران الى اخره يبتدوا يتفاهموا حول
مستقبل اليمن ويساعدوا اهله لتجاوز
عثراتهم
لماذا فمعظم دول اوروبا الوزيري يعتبر هو
الرئيس الفعلي يعني ايه اللي وصلهم لكده
وهل لو اتطبقت النظم دي عندنا هيحل ازمه
الطمع على الحكم
نعتقد انت بتكمل على سؤال سابق الدول
اوروبا اولا دول اوروبا ليست على قلب رجل
واحد انت في الغالب تشير الى الدول اوروبا
الغربيه اللي هي استقرت من سنوات طويله
انت بتتكلم على بريطانيا وبتتكلم على
فرنسا وبتتكلم على دول شمال اوروبا انت
بتتكلم على دوله زي السويد اخر مره حكمها
ديكتاتور على سبيل المثال كان في القرن 17
ما يعرفوش حاكم ديكتاتور من اكثر من 300
سنه بتتكلم على دول استقرت من سنين طويله
جدا جدا جدا وعندها تجربه عميقه في الحكم
بريطانيا لما نشوف تاريخ بريطانيا وقد ايه
الحروب الاهليه اللي دبت بينها والصراع ما
بين الملك وحاشيته
وما بين القوى
البازغه جديده البرجوازيه الجديده او
اصحاب
صغار الملاك
ضد الطبقه الحاكمه ديت
والصراع ما بين الكنيسه وما بين الملكيه
يعني خدوا كل انواع الصرع حتى تستقر البلد
على الشكل اللي هي فيه احنا بينقصناش حاجه
احنا هنا زي بريطانيا زي ايطاليا اللي خدت
عشرات خدت قرون علشان تصل الى ايطاليا
اللي موجوده الان احنا
تجربتنا في الدوله الحديثه قريبه في الدول
اصغر مني انا انا مواليد سنه 69 في دول
عربيه يعني زي بعض الدول الخليج مواليد 71
ما يعني انها تجربه جديده يعني دول مش
يعني دوله عجوزه زي ليبيا مثلا انت بتتكلم
على ايه الاربعينات الخمسينات دوله حديثه
دوله اللي هي اقدم بلد في العالم زي مصر
تاريخ استقلالها انت فانت بتتكلم على متى
حكمها مصر ايوه كانت الدوله موجوده تحت
الاحتلال لكن اول حاكم يحكمها من مئات
السنين كان محمد نجيب وجمال عبد الناصر من
حوالي 70 سنه فيعني القصه ان احنا حديثي
عهد
بالمؤسسات الدوله الحديثه
وبالتالي يعني احنا محتاجين سنوات اطول
كتير عشان تستقر اوضاعنا زي الدول الغربيه
الكبيره اللي انت بتقول عليها
كيف ترى مستقبل مشاريع السعوديه والله ده
مرتبط ده اخونا يا شاعر ده مرتبط بامور
كثيره واحد انه انه ربنا يوفق وتظل يعني
دلوقتي المصدر الرئيسي للسعوديه ولمعظم
دول الخليج هو البترول والغاز المساله
مرهونه بقد ايه تظل هذه الطفره الكبيره
نسال الله ان يطيلها يعني لفتره طويله وان
هم ينجحوا في توظيف هذه الاموال بشكل رشيد
ويوظفوها في مشاريع
قابله للاستمرار
ووظفوا كل قدراتهم البشريه ويبقى عندهم
رؤيه واضحه بيكملوا ده يبقى جميل جدا انما
كل دي بتبقى عليها لان هو كل دول الخليج
ساعه من فتره مبكره ان هي تنوع اقتصادها
بحيث تبعد عن النفط والغاز لكن كان دايما
الحافز قليل
وما نجحوش ده بشكل كبير الحقيقي يمكن يمكن
تكون
الامارات شويه سبقت الكويت عندها صندوق
استثمار ضخم من فتره مبكره فبالتالي
الاجابه مرهونه بنجاح هذه الدول في
الاستفاده في دوام الاول التدفقات ديت
اللي ساهمت فيها بشكل كبير الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه السفر الدول الخليج ونجاحهم هو
في استغلال هذه الثروات بشكل ايجابي
نحن في لبنان اصبحنا نتعامل بالدولار ندفع
ونسعر بالدولار كل السلع والخدمات فما
الذي يمنع الحكومه من التخلي عن الليره
اللبنانيه كعمله رسميه واستبدالها
بالدولار والهذا ممكن او سبق تطبيقه في
دوله ما في الدول ظروفها بائسه
ولا يمكن ابدا هيستغل الدولار الا اذا كان
عنده اقتصاد منهر اساسا ليه انت علشان
يبقى عندك عمله الدولار المشكله مش في ان
الدولار قوي يعني يعني المشكله مش في ان
الليره كانت وحشه المشكله ان انت عندك
اقتصاد سيء واداره سيئه ادت الى انهيار
العمله المحليه لك انت بتعمل ايه الناس ما
عندهاش ثقه في العمله المحليه اذا كانت
ليره او غير ليره فبيقول والله انا هعتمد
على معيار
اكثر
يعني
زي الدولار او اليورو وهستخدمه بس انت
عندك مشاكل انت هتجيب الدولار منين اصلا
ما انت علشان تستخدمه لازم يكون عندك انت
هتجيب الدولار منين
ايمن السلام عليكم ورحمه الله كيف حالك يا
استاذنا
الكريم سيد ممكن تقدم لنا سلسله حلقات على
غرار حلقه الاحداث عام 1979 وخاصه رئيسه
الوزراء مرج للتاتشر
انا فكرت يعني فكرت اعمل العام مثلا 45
فكرت اعمل
1991 في اعوام في التاريخ بصفه عملها
خصوصيه يعني ممكن يعني ممكن لا يعني والله
فكره مش بطاله يعني
رجاء ممكن تحفظ فيديو البث المباشر ما
احنا بنعمل كده مش احنا بنعمل كده يعني
احنا بعد ما بنخلص
بيبقى متروك هو موجود على القناه بس يبدو
ان هو بيبقى ظاهر على على الصفحه من بره
بتاع القناه
بيبقى ظاهر في قائمه اسمها لايف ممكن ترجع
له بس انا كل الفيديوهات موجوده يعني
[موسيقى]
رجاء اه السلام عليكم الجنيه يتعوم الف
مره وقبل كل عمليه تعويم ليه الخبراء
والصحف الاجنبيه كل مره يحددوا السعر
العادل بشكل جديد مثلما مثلا لما كانت 18
قالوا ان السعر العدد 24 وبعد مرتين تعويم
اصبح السعر العادل 35
ده اخونا
عبد الرحمن عبد الرحمن اولا يعني ايه سعر
عادل انت مؤسسه بتيجي بتطلع على البيانات
اللي متاحه لها وغالبا كلهم عندهم
البيانات المؤسسات الكبيره
وبيشوف قد ايه
مصر انت بتتكلم على مصر قد ايه الدولار
عليه قد ايه الجنيه عليه ضغوط يعني الطلب
على الجنيه المصري قد ايه
الطلب على الدولار قد ايه او العملات
الاجنبيه الاخرى انت مطلوب منك ديون قد
ايه مطلوب منك واردات قد ايه وانت هتصدر
بقد ايه وهتصنع بقد ايه الى اخره وشوف
الارقام في فتره زمنيه معينه معينه وبيحسب
التضخم في مصر وبيعسم التضخم في الولايات
المتحده احنا عاملين كذا حلقه عن الموضوع
دي ممكن ترجع له يعني تحديد السعر
تحديد السعر العدد بيتم ازاي
طيب لما بتحدد انت سعر العادل ما بين مصر
والسعوديه ما بين مصر والولايات المتحده
في فتره زمنيه بتقول والله انا شايف بعد
كل البيانات ديت ان سعر الجنيه قدام
الدولار المفروض يكون 25 في ظل المعلومات
دي بتغيب ثلاث اربع شهور وبتحصل تطورات
كثيره فالث اربع شهور حرب امن في التلات
اربع شهور
البلد ما قدرتش ان هي تدير الملفات زي ما
هي كانت قالت ان انا هطرح برنامج طروحات
حكوميه ما طرحتوش لاي سبب قالت ان انا
هبيع ما بعدش قالت ان انا هكتسب استثمارات
انا بدي مثل مصر او غيرها فطبيعي ان السعر
ده مش مقدس هم قدروه بناء على معطيات في
هذه اللحظه زي الجي بي اس المسافه من هنا
لغايه هنا ادي 25 دقيقه في اللحظه الراهنه
بعد ثلاث دقائق الدنيا اتغيرت 25 دقيقه
اللي انت رايح فيها بتاعك بقت 35 بقت 10
دقايق لان المعطيات تغيرت فانت في بعض
الناس ما بتوفقش في تقدير السعر العادل
لكن معظم الاوقات المعطيات بتتغير والفتره
الزمنيه بتتغير مش هيفضل السعر العادل
عادل على طول بالنسبه لعمله ما
مساء الخير سيد نتمنى حلقه عن المفكر
الكبير نعومه تشومسكي مرهق جدا يعني طول
الوقت في ذهني
ربنا يدي له الصحه وطوله العمر يعني انما
حاضر هي دايما في ذهني ودائما محطوطه
قدامي بس عمليه مرهقه لانه الراجل متعدد
الاهتمامات وعميق جدا جدا يكتب في علوم
الانجويستكس طبعا احنا مش هنتكلم عن بس
انا بدات علاقتي بان هو لينجوست يعني
بيكتب في مجالات كثيره جدا من السياسه
والتاريخ والفلسفه وكتب كثيره جدا وما زال
حتى الان وهو في التسعينات راجل وافر
العطاء والله انصحكم اللي ممكن بيعرف لغه
انجليزيه ويبحث عن اراء نعومه لن يندم
ابدا حتى ولو كل اسبوع يقرا له
مقاله او مقالتين
وعند انترفيوس كتير عاملها يعني اللي ما
يحبش يقرا مقاله كامله على موضوع واحد هل
يطيح جمال مبارك بالرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
والله لو ترشح للانتخابات وعنده يعني
جماهير اكتر
ما الذي يمنع ان يفوز بس انا مش شايف انه
راجل اعلن انه هيترشح ولا مساله الحمله
الانتخابيه بدات من اساسه
ما رايك بتحركات وزير الخارجيه السعودي
اتجاه الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه معرفش ان
في تحركات يعني
دراميه غير انه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الامارات دول اخرى من خارج المنطقه
العربيه ارادت ان هي تلعب ادوار وسيطه
لتهدئه الازمه او لتخفيف من حدتها بما انه
القدره على انهاء الازمه متعثر حتى على
الدول الكبرى فضلا عن الدول الاقليميه
انما ما يدعو للبهجه ان السعوديه الامارات
الجزاء كل الدول معظم الدول العربيه
تقريبا اتخذت موقف بتراعي فيه مصالحها ولا
تنصاع لاحد لا للامريكان ولا لغير
الامريكان
ما تطورات الملف النووي الايراني ده عاوز
حلقه كامله لان التطورات خطيره جدا يا
اخونا مش عارفه اقرا الاسم
اللي كان حاصل قبل 2023
اللي كان حاصل من زمان قوي انه خلاص كانوا
وجدوا حل في الاتفاق النووي اللي وقع فيه
يوليو 2015
خرج منه ترامب في مايو 2020
2018 بدات مايو 2019 ايران تتخفف من
الاتفاق وبالتالي اصبحت ايران بتقول
للمجتمع الدولي
انا مش ملزمه ببنود هذا الاتفاق اللي كان
بيقيد قدرتي على تطوير برنامج النووي انا
مقيده فقط بالاتفاق اللي معظم دول العالم
موقعه عليه وهي معاهده عدم الانتشار عدم
انتشار السلاح النووي وانا لن اخالف هذا
الاتفاق وهفضل مشيه في ظل هذا الاتفاق بس
الاتفاق ده هي بتلتزم به بدهاء خطير جدا
لا تخالفه ولكن كل اللي بتعمله يثير القلق
ما هو الاتفاق
بيسمح ان انت تخصب اليورينيوم طبعا ما لوش
علاقه الاتفاق لها بالصواريخ ولا بكل
التكنولوجيات اللي ممكن تساعدك على
استخدام قنبله نوويه هم شغالين كده
بيطوروا صواريخ بيطوروا قدراتهم العسكريه
على كل الصعود
وبالنسبه للتخصيب اللي هو خاضع للاتفائيه
يقول لك الاتفاقيه ما بتمنعنيش ان انا
خاصه بعشرين في الميه عاده الدول بتخسر
اتنين خمسه في الميه للاغراض المدنيه يقول
لك انا ال 20% و60% وممكن اكثر لك انا
محتاجه كده لاغراض علميه ويطلع قائمه
ويقول لك مره الدكتور يسري ابو شادي قال
لي الاتفاق الدولي ده ما بيمنعش ان دوله
تخصب حتى فوق التسعين في الميه لو انت
عندك سبب ان انت عاوز تعمل انفجار مثلا
تفجر نهر ولا تفجر جبل ولا يعني ده كلام
نظري طبعا يعني
فهم بيقولوا ما تمسكوش علينا غلطه احنا
ماشيين بالقانون انما كلامهم ده بيوحي
بانه هم بيلاعبوا المجتمع الدولي والمجتمع
الدولي كمان بيضغط عليهم وعلى حافه انه مش
لاقي حل لعارف يصل بعمله اتفاق ولا قادر
يفكر في استخدام القوه العسكريه لكل
الاسباب اللي انا قلتها الجديد الاسباب
اللي احنا قلناها كتير يعني انه الحاله
العسكريه مش هيجيب نتيجه في دوله امتلكت
بالفعل التكنولوجيا النوويه في ناس عندهم
تصور انه انا هعمل زي ما عملت في العراق
وسوريا العراق وسوريا كانت برامج اقل كانت
مكشوفه كان لو تم ضرب مبنى اتنين تقريبا
المشكله خلصت انما ايران تقدمت بشكل كبير
جدا عندها مواقع ضخمه جدا الى ضرب واحد
اتنين تلاته اربعه خمسه سته هياجل
البرنامج لن ينهيه التكنولوجيا موجوده في
عقول العلماء الايرانيين العمليه صعبه
واذا ضربت هيكون مبرر ان انا لن اخرج حتى
من اتفاق الاساسي وبالتالي تصبح كوريا
شماليه جديده
الخطر في المساله انه الامريكان مرتبكين
في الملف الايراني زي ما هم مرتبطين في
ملفات كثيره
الياقوت حمله العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليين واللي بيحكم اسرائيل الان
مجموعه من القوى المتطرفه اللي مازومه
داخليا الخوف كل الخوف ان تفلت منهم
الاوضاع ويجدوا نفسهم ارتكبوا عمل ايران
ما تقدرش تتجاهله وتقول ان انا مش شايفاه
ما هي ضربت ايران وعملت نفسها مش شايفها
لان هي بتامل تكسب وقت عشان توصل لمستوى
اعلى من التخصيب توصل
لتطويق اكبر لاسرائيل
تتجاوز على امل ان هي ما توقعش عليها
عقوبات
فبتكسب وقت فالخوف كل الخوف انه اسرائيل
تعمل عمليه ايران تجد نفسها مضطره للرد
وتفلت الاوضاع من الجميع واحنا اول من
يتضرر من هذه القضيه من هذه الصراع للاسف
يعني احنا مين كل الدول العربيه
توقعاتك عن سياسه الفيدرالي بالاستمرار في
رفع الفائده ما فيش توقعات ده هو الراجل
قال هو كاتب توقعات انه احنا وصلنا للذروع
وانه المتوقع انه هينتهي 23 بحوالي خمسه
ونصف في الميه وبعدين يبتدي يقلل الفايده
احنا فوجئنا انه الفيدرالي بيقول والله
انا
التضخم اكثر عنادا مما توقعنا رفعنا
للفائده لمستوى يقترب هو دلوقتي 34 يعني
نقول خمسه في الميه للتقريب انه ده مش
واضح ان ده يعني كفايه انه ينزل التضخم
للمستوى اللي احنا عاوزينه اثنين وثلاثه
في الميه ما يعني انه هيضطر انه يرفع
الفائده بدل ما كنا متوقعين هيرفعها
لمستوى الخمسه المره الجايه ربما يرفعها
نص يبقى خمسه وربع ولن يكون هذا من نهايه
المطاف وطبعا هو عنده اصرار مهما كلفوا
الامر هيرفع الفايده الى ان
لانه عنده استعداد
انه ممكن يصيب الاقتصاد بالركود على امل
انه يستعيد الثقه في التضخم زي ما شرحنا
في حلقات سابقه قبل كده كتير يعني
لماذا هناك تصور سائد عن دول الخليج انها
الدول بدون سياده بالرغم ما تملكه من
مستشارين اقتصاديين ودعم من مراكز ابحاث
وبعض اللوبيات القويه لا مش عارف مين اللي
بيقول يعني احنا معتصم ده اللي بيسال
السؤال كان تصور قديم لانها كانت الدول
يعني عندها ثروات وهي الدول
مساحتها صغيره عدد سكانها صغير وكانت دول
حديثه زي ما بقول لحضرتك فكانت مطمع ايران
طمعانه فيها العراق طبعا في مصر ايام عبد
الناصر كانت يعني طمعانه فيها او مستعده
ان هي يعني
تلزمها بسياستها طبعا الدول الكبيره
الولايات المتحده الاتحاد السوفيتي فده ما
كانش حاجه سر وما هيش حاجه عيب يعني لانه
انا دوله وليده عدد سكاني نص مليون او
مليون وعندي ثروه ضخمه هعمل ايه مع ايران
ولا هعمل ايه حتى مع العراق ولا مع مصر في
الستينات والسبعينات كده يعني انما الان
لا
الظروف اللي حصلت بعد 2011 وما قبل 2011
خلت الدول الخليجيه بقت في صداره المشهد
وبقت هي تقود تقريبا التحركات الرئيسيه في
المنطقه العربيه ده مش حاجه كويسه ولا
وحشه يعني اكيد بالنسبه لهم حاجه مش وحشه
بس مش حاجه ايجابيه قوي برده لان هم في
حاجه انه تكون في دول عربيه اخرى
بعافيتها علشان تدعمهم في كثير من
التحديات اللي موجوده يعني الدول الخليجيه
مش هتستفيد ان هي
تبقى العراق واقع وسوريا منهاره ومصر
منقبه على ازماتها لا الوضع هيبقى صحي لما
بعض هذه الدول على الاقل يتعافى
مصر
مصر عربيه اسلاميه
ماشي الحال يا صديقي انت كاتب حاجه انا مش
فاهمها لكن انت اكيد عندك حكمه يعني من جد
وجد من غير اي مجامله حضرتك من القله
القليله فعلا لتتمتع بالمعلومه الغير
موجهه او مسيسه الله يبارك فيك ربنا يخليك
ويسعدك يا محمد الامير كيف ترى مستقبل
جبنه سيد عدد سيد عدد لنا العناوين او
الحلقات اللي سالك الاخوه تفعلها حلقات
وقت وقلت لهم حاضر لتتاكد من صدقك لو سمحت
انا عارف سؤالك مش بريء خالص يا حسين انت
عندك حق انا فعلا
الناس بيقولوا لي على حلقات وبقول حاضر
والله انا صادقا بكون فعلا بقول انا زي ما
بقول لك النفس راغبه والجسد ضعيف يعني في
عشرات الحلقات انا عندي
كان في تعبير يقول عليه عبد الوهاب
المسيري الاستاذ الكبير الله يرحمه عبد
الوهاب المسيري توفى في 2008
ولو حد ما عرفوش هو كان راجل ليه اسهامات
عظيمه جدا خصوصا في دراسه الصهيونيه وكان
بيستخدم الفاظ عربيه منحوته صعبه كده يعني
فكان يقول ان في حاجه اسمه الاستذابيه
المعلوماتيه استئجابيه جايه الذئب ايه
يقصد يقول لك ان في ناس انا ما كنتش اعرف
انه مرض انه لما يبحث عن حاجه يفضل يبحث
كتير كتير كتير كتير عدم البحث وحش البحث
القليل الفقر لكن
الهوس بفكره انك تتوقر المعلومات وتجمعها
وتوثقها للاسف انا اكتشفت ان انا مصاب
بهذه الاستذابيه المعلوماتيه فدائما
قدام هذا الحاجه يمكن ماندو يعرفها الاقي
عندي مثلا اربعين خمسين حاجه موجوده ولا
لا لسه شويه لم تكتمل لا لو كذا فانا صحيح
انا انا
اقول حاضر لاني انا لا اريد ان اغلق الباب
اقول حاضر من قبيل الرغبه في التجاوب
هيكون من الوقاحه ان انا اقول لا يعني
انما بكون راغب لكن احيانا بتبقى المساله
عاوزه وقت الحلقات بتاخد وقت كتير جدا
فسامحني وانا مقدر سؤالك الماكر يعني
لماذا معظم دول اوروبا الوزير
اخونا وائل بيتكلم عن الوضع في تونس احنا
بنتكلم عليه تقريبا كل مره انا ما اعرفش
التفاصيل في تونس عشان اكون صادقه يعني
اصل في
يعني انا عارف الاطار العام انت عارف في
نوع من الصراعات بتبقى يعني المفروض
الصراع بطبعه ديناميك انما في صراعات هي
دينامك بس استاتيك يعني يعني انت مثلا
تغمض وتفتح في ليبيا هتلاقيهم بيتكلموا عن
القاعده الدستوريه يحتاج ده كتير يحتاج
سنه سنه ونص
تغيب عن الصراع الليبي سنتين ثلاثه وهم
بيتكلموا مثلا على
مين اللي ليه الشرعيه برلمان الشرق ولا
برلمان الغرب تغيب عن وضع مش في تونس قوي
كده بس تغيب كثير عنه نفس الحكايه في
السودان نفس الحكايه في تونس بتلاقي انه
من حوالي سنه ونصف سنتين مش بنتحرك كثير
انما الافق انت لما بتكون عندك
يعني هي انت عندك النهارده حاله جدل واسعه
اطراف الفاعله في تونس مش قادره تتوافق
على ان تحكم نفسها مش قادرين يعيشوا مع
بعض مش مشكله تونس بس ده مشكله تونس
ومشكله دول كتيره لبنان عندك السودان عندك
ليبيا مش قادرين يعيشوا مع بعض بس مشكله
بلد زي ليبيا غير بلد زي تونس ليبيا خلاص
الارض يتدفق البترول بيتدفق الناس بتاخد
الفلوس بيصرفوا على
يعني
مناظرات السياسيه لهم فمش قلقانين قوي
انما بلدي تونس هجيب منين
فاسال الله ان هم يعني انه يقدروا
يتوافقوا
وتتحل المشكله التي لا ارى لها افقا قريبا
يعني
اهلا بحضرتك وشكرا لك ربنا يخليك استاذ
ممكن لو سمحت وضع سوريا بخصوص القمه
ان هي تحضر القمه العربيه او لا تحضر ما
انا لسه كنت بكلم حضرتك لو بتتكلم على
القمه العربيه يعني بتتكلم على القمه
العربيه يا استاذه كوثر لو وضحت اكون شاكر
بس لو بتتكلموا على عوده
سوريا الى الدول العربيه وان هي تشارك فيه
المنتج انا لسه كنت بقوله انه في صراع غير
محسوم الصراع الغير المحسوم ده
انت بتبوظ البث يا ماندو
بتعدل البث
انه الصراع غير المحسوم ده ما بين طيار
يعتقد انه الافضل
شفته هو يعني خلي الشاشه ترقص
الصراع اللي انا كنت لسه بتكلم عليه ما
بين دول ترى انه لا امل في ان هم يقيموا
علاقات بعام بشار الاسد ويبعدوه عن ايران
وما بين التيار اللي بيقول افضل لينا ان
احنا نكتبه
ونلبي له طلباته بحيث ان احنا نبعده عن
ايران يعني هو الليله بتدور حوالين ايران
بشكل رئيسي طبعا في اعتبارات اخرى لانه
المساله مش واقفه على ايران روسيا لها
مطالب تركيا لها مطالب لكن هذا هو المشكله
الاساسيه بالنسبه للدول العربيه وفي دول
عربيه ما عندهاش مشكله مع ايران يعني مصر
ما عندهاش مشكله معي ايران مثلا الجزائر
ما عندهاش مشكله تناقضات كبيره مع ايران
لكن بتبقى علشان الدول الاخرى ما هو لازم
توافق
اما لو قصدك بحاجه تانيه يا ريت تقولي لي
في حال توجيه ضرب عسكريه لايران ماذا سوف
يكون موقف مصري يا رب ما يكونش فيه ضرب
عسكريه لايران لان ضرب عسكريه لايران
المنطقه احنا يعني
اوكرانيا على بعد الاف الاميال مننا ولما
حصلت الضربه احنا كلنا تاثرنا ما فيش طفل
ما فيش واحد ما فيش مستثمر ما فيش طالب ما
فيش موظف ما تاثرش زي ما حد كان بيقول لي
كده انا ما كنتش اسمع يعني
ما كنتش اسمع عن اوكرانيا ثم اكتشفت ان كل
حاجه قايلها من اوكرانيا على سبيل
المبالغه لكن هي هي اثرت الحرب اثرت على
كل واحد فينا اذا لا قدر الله بقت في
عمليه عسكريه في ايران هي مش هتبقى في
ايران هتبقى بين ايران واطراف تانيه لا لا
قدر الله هتبقى حاجه لا يتخيلها احد لانه
الحرب مش هتبقى محظوره في حته مش الناس
هيروحوا يضربوا منطقه ويخرجوا لا حرب
هتمتد وتتسع وهو ده الحاجه الوحيده اللي
منع الولايات المتحده ومنع اسرائيل من
ضربها من سنه 2003 الى الان
السلام عليكم بخصوص ده اسلام بيقول
سلام بخصوص البودكاست انت ممكن تحول
الحلقات بتاعتي حضرتك الوصول بس وترفعها
على منصات البودكاست ما هو مفهوم الاسلام
بس هي يعني انا كده يعني انا
برضو يعني مسموع بس في بودكاست متشاف فانا
مش قادر افهم ايه هو الكونسبت انا الحاجه
الوحيده اللي بلاحظها اولا انا بكتشف انه
ناس كتيره بتسمع الحلقات فده من زمان دي
اي سبب من الاسباب حتى بقابل ناس مثلا
اصدقائي هو مهتم بحلقه عن موضوع معين
مشغلها كده انما انا مش شايف فرق جوهري
يعني تعليقك وتعليق الاخ التاني بيقول انه
اللي احنا بنقدمه شكل من اشكال البودكاست
فممكن ان انا ارفعها صوتي ممكن بس انا
هستفيد ايه انا بحط الحلقات على يوتيوب
وفي بيزنس موديل اليوتيوب
انا ما بعملش اعلانات يعني انا ما هو انا
عندي هنا مثلا ده
حلقات دي لها مكان فيه فريق بيشتغل في ناس
لازم تاخذ مرتباتها انا ما بعملش مرتبات
انا ما باخدش فلوس لا من اي شركه ولا من
اي جهه حكوميه الفلوس الوحيده اللي بتدفع
منها كل التكاليف دي هي بتيجي من النموذج
اللي بيقدمه اليوتيوب فانا بعمل اذا حد
فبيحطه اعلانات الاعلان ده بيجي منه
الفلوس اللي بتنفق على كل مقاومات القناه
وبعدين في منصات بتعمل كده مستحملتش
الماده يعني لما عملت على فيسبوك
بالمناسبه رفضوا المواد اللي انا عملتها
وعندي صفحه فيها 52 الف الناس بيقولوا له
حط عليها فيسبوك مش عاوز بيقول لي لا ده
كنت ريفر ده ماده ده ممنوع ده حساس مش
قابل الماده شايف ان الماده اللي بيقدمها
لا تتوافق مع
سياساته وبالتالي مش عاوز مادتي انها
احطها عنده
مثلا حاجه زي
الخفيف ده اسمه ايه
تيك توك يعني
عاوز احنا بنعمل موضوعات تحليليه كبيره
فعملت بس
بقدم فيعني اذا عملت الكلام ده صوتي
وحطيته يعني هو هو نفس الكلام ولا اقول
حاجه مختلفه يعني لو هو نفس الكلام طب ما
هو موجود على يوتيوب وناس بتسمعه برضه صوت
يعني انما هي فكره مطروح ان انا اعملها
بقى زي مثلا هاني جنينه وانا مثلا ونتوسع
في القصه دي يبقى حوارات مع ناس كثيره في
تخصصات مختلفه اللي هو ده اللي ممكن يكون
مختلف
ونجيب ناس من كده ناس من
حوار ما بين اتنين سؤال اجابه سؤال اجابه
بس هي دي الفكره بتاعته يعني ده يبقى ده
لطيفه ان انا اجيب ناس من تخصصات مختلفه
ويتكلموا
ده يبقى حل لاكتر من حاجه يبقى شكل جديد
وفي نفس الوقت انا قدرتي على ان انا اقدم
حلقه من الحلقات اللي هي الكبيره ديت
هتبقى ايه مره كل خمس ايام اسبوع اكتر من
كده ما عنديش هذه القدره يعني وده بياخدنا
للسؤال او تعليق زميلنا ده بتقول حاضر انا
هقوله ما بتقدمش لان بتاخد كتير جدا كتير
جدا
السلام عليكم
انا شكرا يا اسلام للملحوظه عموما في
الاقتصاد هل هو ممكن في عمله تكون فعلا
مخزن القيمه هي العمله اللي لازم تكون
للقيمه يعني العمله عشان تبقى عمله لها
مجموعه من الشروط واحد ان هي تكون وحده
حسابيه يعني ايه يعني انا اقول مثلا انت
هبيع لك العربيه دي بكام فتقول لي العربيه
دي ب 10,000 دولار يبقى انا وانت عارفين
ال 10,000
بمناسبه الكلام بيجيب بعده انا لما بقول
لواحد العربيه ديت زي مثلا ب 10 مليون
ليره هو مش عارف
يستخدمها كوحده حسابيه لان عماله تتغير
فيقول لي لا سيبنا من الليره ديت اللي هي
امبارح كانت بكذا وبكره بكذا فانا عاوز
حاجه وحده حسابيه انا وانت فاهمينها فنروح
مثلا للدولار او لليورو او لكذا فواحد رقم
واحد ان العمله عشان تبقى عمله تكون وحده
حسابيه
كل فاهمها اتنين تكون مقبوله من عدد كبير
من الناس فالوحده العملات المحليه بتبقى
مقبوله في داخلها لما بتزداد اقتصاد
الدوله بتبقى مقبوله خارجه يعني
انا النهارده زي مثلا الدينار الكويتي
يعني انا مش هعمل له حاجه في هنا مثلا بلد
زي مثلا المغرب لكن ممكن اقبله لان عمله
ممكن الاقي اصرفه اعمله هو رابط نفسه بسله
عملات والدولار تحديدا مفهوم اذا كانت بقى
عمله دوله كبيره زي اليورا والدولار الناس
تاخدها في اي مكان تلاته انها تكون مخزن
قيمه يعني انا قلت انه يكون مقبول من عدد
كبير من الناس لازم يكون مقبول داخل البلد
والا يبقى في مشكله زي مشكله لبنان ان
يكون واحده حسابيه مفهومه عند في اذهان كل
من يتعامل بها
والعامل الثالث ان العمله تبقى عمله يكون
مخزن قيمه انا النهارده اشتغلت
شهر سنه في مكان وجماعه
مبلغ 10,000 دولار 100 الف دولار انا
بعملهم علشان ده ما تبقى من مدخراتي مش
معقوله ان انا اشتغل النهارده واخر الشهر
معي مبلغ الاقيه مش قادر امسكه في جيبي
لانه التضخم بيزيد لحظه بعد لحظه زي ما
حصل في دول كثيره او يكون بصوره اقل مش
بيخسر قيمته يوم بعد يوم بس شهر بعد شهر
في الحاله ديت الناس بتتخلص منه لانه ليس
مخزنا جيدا للقيمه
وعليه فانه
العملات المستقره رغم فيها ذبذبات عشره
15% لكن
طلوع ونزولا لكن هي مخزن ثابت للقيمه لو
كان عندك دولار من من عشر سنين مش هيختلف
كتير قوي يعني عن دلوقتي صعودا او هبوطا
سيد جبيل يعطيك العافيه على ساعه صدرك هل
تتفق بانه اعجبنا في عالم مضطرب
وفي حاله مخاض عصير كما يلاحظ الجميع
برايك يا سيد العالم يتجه الى اين ده هو
ده السؤال اللي تقريبا يعني انا شاغلني من
سنين طويله ومثل الحمد لله في 10 حلقات
بس اعتقد انه بعض الحلقات ربنا كان موفقنا
فيها
وقدمت تفسير مش بطال يعني اعتقد الحلقات
اللي كيف نفهم العالم مثلا في كلمه واحده
لما اتكلمت على كلمه
وان احنا عايشين في مرحله انتقاليه واللي
عبرت عنه بطرق تانيه يعني في حلقات تانيه
باسماء مختلفه
ان العالم في مرحله فعلا انتقاليه
والمرحله الانتقاليه دي بتثور فيها
الاضطرابات الكثيره اذا ما تقتصاديه حروب
انقلابات ثورات العالم يتجه الى اين هو ده
السؤال اللي ما اقدرش اقرا المستقبل بس
احنا قدامنا مرحله انتقاليه فيها صراعات
العالم بيتجه الى تشكيل نظام جديد قوه
بتصعد قوه ممكن القوه الصاعده تفضل صاعده
وتقضي على القوه الصاعده الاخرى زي الصين
او روسيا او غيره او يعني دول او غيره
يعني وبالتالي العالم بيتجه على المدى
القريب والسنوات المقبله لصراع الصراع ده
يسرع عن ايه في علم الله
السلام عليكم نريد حلقه خاصه بالسلاح
النووي ومدى ارتباط النظام العالمي الحالي
بعدم استعماله ولماذا لم يستعمل منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه الى اليوم وكيف سقط
الاتحاد السوفيتي دون استعمال القوه
بالنسبه للسلاح النووي انا في تقريبا يمكن
انا عامل مع الدكتور يسري ابو شادي بس
تقريبا حوالي 22 حلقه بتتكلم عن كل ما هو
نووي
ليه لم تستخدم السلاح النووي من الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كاد العالم يستخدم
السلاح النووي في ازمات لحظات قليله
اشهرها اكتوبر 62 اللي هي ازمه الصواريخ
الكوبيه
لماذا لم يستخدم لانه سلاح نهايه العالم
انت هتستخدم النووي ضد دوله والدوله
هتستخدم دوله نوويه ولا غير نوويه
الصراع بين القوه الكبرى دول نوويه تستخدم
السلاح النووي سوف يستخدم ضدك السلاح
النووي وبالتالي السلاح النووي على كل
شروره من الجوانب الايجابيه له انه حفظ
استقرار العالم فيما يتعلق بالصرع على
مستوى القوى الكبرى كل واحد عارف انه
يعني يفكر مليا لانه اذا استخدم النووي
سوف يستخدم ضده ويستخدم النوى من الجانبين
انتهى العالم
والدول الاخرى حافظت امانها يعني الصراع
بين الهند وباكستان العامل الاساسي فيه هو
السلاح النووي هم صحيح خاضوا حروب ودي
حاله استثنائيه
الدولتين النوويتين الوحيتين في التاريخ
طبعا التاريخ الحديث لان ما كانش فيه نووي
قبل سنه 45
لخدوا عده حروب بس بالاسلحه التقليديه
يعني اسلحه محدوده وكل دوله عارفه ان هو
اذا حست ان هي سوف تغلب تماما هتستخدم
النووي فدائما الحروب بتبقى محدوده
كم تتوقع حرب اوكرانيا او روسيا ان تستمر
سوف تستمر طويلا وانا قلت لحضرتك يعني
انه احد اصدقائنا
في برنامج كلام في السياسه زميلنا الاستاذ
احمد الطاهري كان بيسال يعني عن توقعات في
منتصف الحرب كده فانا كان تقديري انه
الحرب سوف تطول واديت مؤشر على ان
الامريكان كان تخطيطهم للحرب ديت بعد
اندلاعب عده شهور لدحو ثلاث سنوات
بس انا تقدير انه ممكن تطول كثيرا سواء
انه الحرب تفضل حرب
او تصمت وتفضل وضع مشتعل ده مش حاجه غريبه
في حروب كثيره كلنا نعرفها مش استمر
التلات سنين ولا عشر سنين استمرت كتير جدا
بس بدل ما هو صراع مشتعل جدا بيكون صراع
هادي اليمن بدا مشتعل في 2015 موازاه
مستمر بعد اكتر من 8 سنوات لكنه اهداء
الاطراف طرهق
الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه قعدت 8 سنوات بس
مشتعله
الصراع على كشمير من سنه 47 الى الان
كتير يعني لا الصراعات
والصراع بين ارمينيا
بدا مؤشراته في 88 وما زال الى اليوم
مشتعل بس يعني يروح ويجي كتير قوي
كوريا الشماليه وكوريا الجنوبيه الهدنه
الحرب بدات خمسين انتهت 53 بهدنه هدنه حتى
الان ما فيش توقيع اتفاق سلام وما زال حتى
الان الصراع مستمر من سنه 53 بعد توقفه
الى الان
مساء الخير استاذ سيد نتمنى حلقه اه
هل دائما ايوه ماذا ترى مستقبل العراق هل
ترى تغييرها في السياسات الاقليميه اتجاه
العراق السؤال الثاني هي كيف ترى سياسه
المانيا بشكل مختصر
طيب انا اتكلمت كتير عن موضوع العراق فما
دام انت بتتكلم بشكل مختصر ده المانيا
فوجئت بما حدث وهي في مفترق طرق هو اللحظه
اللي بتمر بها المانيا زي بعض الدول لم
تحسب حسابها ابدا المانيا كانت بانيه
حسابتها على انه هيظلل السلام مستقر الى
الابد وان الحرب دي شيء من الماضي
ونوعت وبنت اقتصاد عظيم حوالي خمسه
تريليون دولار او اقل قليلا
والاقتصاد ده مبني على تشابكات على
الحمايه الامريكيه وعلى الايدي العامله
الرخيصه الصينيه وعلى الطاقه الرخيصه من
روسيا التلاته دول بيتصارعوا الان وهي في
المنتصف
عاجزه عن ان هي
تحسم كثير من الخيارات لكن مع طول امد
الحرب اذا طالت وتتمنى هي انها تطول
المانيا هتخسر كثير
وهتضطر ان هي تحسم كثير من خياراتها
بتسويه قدراتها العسكريه بحسم خياراتها في
التعاون على فكره الخلاف مش هيبقى مع
روسيا بس والناس متوقعين الناس ده ممكن
جدا تطورات الحرب تؤدي الى ان الصراع يكون
كمان مش لازم يكون يعني صراع يعني بالحرب
لكن الخلافات مع الولايات المتحده وما
تنسوش ان في قضيه شائكه الان المانيا
بتتكتم عليها وهو من فجر خطوط
تفجرها اولا المانيا انفقت عليها
المليارات ثم انه الحرب كانت تنتهي
وكان في امل ان الغاز الروسي يرجع تاني
ضرب
الخطين خلد ده اصبح شيء شبه مستحيل لسنوات
مقبله وابناء عليه فهو اجبرها على تغيير
سياساتها تجاه روسيا بشكل كبير واللي عمل
كده ما كانش يريد يعني ان هو
ساعه المانيا على قفزه الثقه في المياه ده
عاوز يغرقها وبالتالي لسه التحقيقات
وقضايا اخرى ممكن تغير مواقف الالمان لكن
الاجابه المختصره انه المانيا بتمر زي ما
قال مستشارهم بمرحله تحول هو كان بيتكلم
على العالم كله لكن اكتر على المانيا
الروس انتهت دوله الديكتاتور المستبد سفاح
وطاغيه والفاسد والمستبد والقاتل خلاص يا
محمد
ارجوك تشرح لنا قلناها في حاله توجيه ضرب
عسكريه لايران اه قلنا
هل انتصرت سوريا على المؤامره الامريكيه
القطريه
عاوزين منك تحليل عن شكل المنطقه في حال
نجاح الولايات المتحده في اسقاط النظام
الايراني والاتيان بنظام زي نظام الشاه
كيف ستتغير التحالفات في المنطقه اللي انت
بتتكلم على يعني
تتكلم على يعني تغيير
رهيب
ده عاوز عاوز اجهزه مايكروسوفت كلها وجوجل
علشان تحط ايه الاحتمالات اللي تكون
موجوده يعني لا الدنيا تتغير تماما لو ده
حدث يعني
وهي مش هتنجح على الامور ممكن تدمر ايران
بس ما تعرفش تغير النظام
هي ما نجحتش فنزويلا وما نجحتش في
افغانستان ومناجحتش في سوريا وما نجحتش في
حاجه يعني ففكره ان هي تنجح في بلد زي
ايران تفتكر يعني ممكن وما رجعتش في
العراق بالمناسبه هل تتوقع ان حرب
اوكرانيا وروسيا ان تستمر الى 10 سنوات
مثل حرب فيتنام وارد جدا السلام عليكم ما
تنساش ان حرب الاتحاد السوفيتي في
افغانستان افغانستان استمر 10 سنوات
السلام عليكم عندي استفسار ده فايب ليه
روسيا ما تدمر الاسلحه الغربيه عن طريق
قصف الطائرات والمطارات ما عنديش اجابه
والله انا عندي سؤال اسهل
في سلسله قطارات
ومطارات حيه جدا وهي تحت وسمع الاجهزه
الروسيه ايه اللي بيمنعها من انها تاخد
الخطوه ديت انا مش قادر اعرف اجابه
في الاول كان مفهوم ويمكن يكون هو السبب
في الاول هي ما كانتش عاوز تدمر كل البنيه
التحتيه مش عاوزه التصعيد يكون عنيف لان
هي عاوزه تسيطر على البلد عاوزه تعمل
تغيير باقل قدر ممكن من خسائر في الدوله
اللي ترغب ان هي تبقى دوله تابعه لها
ثلاث تغير السياسه ابتدت تضرب المرافق لكن
ما زالت هناك مرافق زي زي القطارات اللي
بتحمل الاسلحه اللي بتستغلها
روسيا هل العسكريين بيقولوا احنا مش
محتاجين نضرب القطارات لان احنا هنحتاجها
فيما بعد هل احنا بنضرب مثلا ما نستطيع من
شحنات قبل ان تصل للقطارات لا ادري
الحقيقه ما عنديش تفسير منطقي يعني
هل ورقه اخيره انه اذا ضاق بيهم الحالي
دمروا كل المطارات طب وايه هو تاثير ضرب
المطارات يعني هو ما عندوش سلاح طيران
بيهدد القوات
الروسيه بشكل كبير
ما توقعاتك بالنسبه لسوريا وبشار الاسد
نسبه لسوريا هي الحرب الساخنه انتهت انما
في مجموعه كبيره من الصراعات اللي هي يعني
الارهاق اسكتها يعني ما زالت الصراع مش
بقى يعني يعني مرتبطه المساله بحسابات
القوى الرئيسيه حسابات تركيا مع ايران مع
روسيا وطبعا
الولايات المتحده اسرائيل لها دور في
المساله دول الخليج كل دول
بيتجذبوا سوريا ومعاها بشار الاسد والقوه
الاخرى في اتجاهات المختلفه فهتبقى عامله
كده زي برضو مساله متروكه الاحتمالات
كثيره توافق الدول ديت
هو اللي هيحدد مستقبل سوريا
سؤال هل سينقسم
العراق وسوريا الى سنه وشيعه يعني تفتكر
ده يحل المشكله يعني هل ينقسم ينقسم عراق
وسوريا يعني تفتكر ده يحل المشكله طب ما
هي كان في يعني صيغه كده عملوها في العراق
هل العراق بقى اكثر امنا لما كردستان بقى
عندها حكم ذاتي بقى الوضع افضل مثلا
استقرت هدات المسائل اذا كان ده هيبقى
بالتوافق لا باس بس ده تم في العراق بعد
تجربه طويله وقوه كبيره كانت موجوده
موجوده على الارض وبتحاول تفرض صيغ مختلفه
على الاطراف المحليه وكان في برضو نوع من
القبول انما تفتكر ده هيكون موجود في
سوريا ومش قوه واحده عشرات القوه مش عشرات
يعني قوه كثيره موجوده
حفظ الفيديو احنا بنعمله كده بالفعل اخونا
والله بنحفظ الفيديو
نحن في لبنان اصبحنا اكدنا
استاذ سيد جبيل يعطيك العافيه على ساعه
صدرك اجابنا هل تم اغتيال مصر اقتصاديا
بعد الانخراط في اقتصاد السوق وربطتها
بالاقتصاد الامريكي ما تمش اغتيال مصر
اقتصاديا ولا حاجه هو اللي بيحصل انه مصر
زي دول كثيره
دوله ناميه والدوله الناميه دي زي ما كنت
بتكلم دايما بيكون عندها الاقتصاد بتاعها
مش يعني
دايما محتاج بيعتمد كتير على الواردات
وسلع رئيسيه زي ما كنت بقول دايما بيحتاج
الى قروض العالم عايش على قروض بس الفرق
ان في دول عندها قدره ان هي تقترض باسعار
افضل وعندها قدره ان هي
تساوم اكتر مش معقوله يعني انه هتقارن انه
بلد زي اليابان زي بلد زي مصر او المغرب
او السودان فيعني ايه الدول الناميه
ظروفها صعبه بس بتبقى بتنكشف جدا وبتتعب
جدا في اوقات الازمات والازمه مش على قد
مصر انا مش عارف ليه المساله دي مش واضحه
والله وبعدين يتم التسيسها يعني اللي عنده
مشكله مع الحكومه بيركز على فشل الحكومه
وان الدوله بتنهار هي الدوله انا مش شايف
الوضع في مصر صعب جدا جدا جدا لكنه مش
اصعب من عشرات الدول حوالين العالم يعني
انا لما بشوف الاقتصاد البريطاني بندهش
لما بشوف الاقتصاد او الضغوط اللي موجوده
على دول
يعني دول اغلب كتير بندهش ومع ذلك
العمليه المسيسه اللي ضد
الرئيس الدوله او الرئيس السيسي هو طول
الوقت بيسايس المساله على انه دي حاله
فريده في الانهيار واللي مع الحكومه ومع
الرئيس بيصور على انه مصر مش متاثره خالص
لا مصري متاثره ومتاثره جدا والوضع
الاقتصادي ما في شك صعب لكن الانصاف يقول
ان هي ليست حاله فريده في العالم كله
وبالتالي علينا ان احنا نقيم الموقف في
حدوده
في حال توجيه لاجابنا
هل تتفق استاذ سيد الكريم ان بالرغم من
ارتكاب الولايات المتحده افعال الاجراميه
في العقود السابقه لانها ضبطت العالم
وجنبته حروب كثيره لان العالم كالغابه اذا
لم يكن هناك اسد قوي
ستعمول فوضى طبعا احيانا ده صحيح ده موجود
بس ده بيكون يعني فائده جانبيه لنظام لا
يسعى الا لتحقيق مصالحه من ضمن فوائده
الجانبيه ان هو بيحسم اي صراع في اتجاه
واحد فما بيسمعش غير بالسناري واحد فخلاص
فانت وقعلم استفدت انت ما عندكش خيارين زي
الاب اللي في البيت انت اخرج انت اقعد انت
خذ انت لا تاخذ بس ما فيش صراعات في ظلم
اه في ناس متضرره اه لكن ما فيش فوضى
عاوزين منك تحليل عن شكل المنطقه في حل
اجابنا من هي الدوله صاحبه الفرصه الاكبر
للفوز في اوكرانيا امريكا او روسيا
اوكرانيا ما عندهاش اي فرص للفوز اوكرانيا
عندها فرصه واحده بس ان هي تنجو بما تبقى
لها من مؤسسات افتكروا ان اوكرانيا دي بلد
فيها بشر فيها اطفال فيها سيدات فيها رجال
فيها دوله لوحدها شعب يعني الشعب ده خسر
بلده الشعب ده لو توقفت الحرب اليوم
واذا اختفت روسيا من على الوجود واذا تم
تقديم بوتين وكل زعماء الروس هي ده لن
يفيد اوكرانيا كثيرا لانه اوكرانيا تم
تدميرها ومع طول امد الحرب لن يبقى منها
شيئا
فانت بتتكلم اوكرانيا يعني خاسر صافي ما
عندهاش حاجه تفوز بها ده رايي اما امريكا
وروسيا روسيا عندها خسائر على المدى
القريب والمتوسط في تقديري وامريكا عندها
خسائر على المدى البعيد ربما تندم عليها
ودي قصه احنا اتكلمنا عنها قبل كده عموما
يعني لكن ممكن نطرحها فيه
نقاط اخرى لو حبيته
هذا ما يبدو ليه يعني وطبعا الامور بتتغير
رده فعل الشعوب الاوروبيه بعد الحرب اظهرت
اما نفاق او جهل بكلى الحالتين ما هي قيمه
الديمقراطيه والثقافه التي تعيشها شعوب
العالم الاول عندما تكون سياسه الدوله
تقاد غالبا على اساس مصلحه النخبه في جميع
الاحوال ده سؤال زي قريب من السؤال ده ادم
ادم ده سؤال بيتكلم عن جدول الديمقراطيه
وفي الاخر نحن لا نعيش في
جمهوريه افلاطون جمهوريه افلاطون ما كانتش
حلوه يعني الراجل كان
مقسم المجتمع بشكل طبقي لكن يعني بيسموها
بلاتونيك يبقى افلاطونيه مثاليه
احنا لا نعيش في الجنه
احنا عايشين على الارض وطبيعه الارض دائما
فيه صراع زي ما بقول لحضرتك انت هات اي
نظام يعجبك هتلاقي دايما انه الناس الاذكى
الاقوى الاغنى هم المستفيدين حط اي قانون
عمل
واتركوا وعندك صاحب عمل وعامل مين صاحب
اليد العليا حتى لو في قوانين ونقابه
بتدعمه كويس ده هيساعدوا لكن في النهايه
انا كصاحب عمل انا اللي عندي الابر هاند
وانت العامل فانت
انت الطرف الادنى في هذه العلاقه اي مجتمع
اي مجتمع فيه نسبه من الناس مهما تشكلت
الانظمه مهما جتهم عندهم قدرات اعلى هم
بيستفيدوا من النظام بيستفيدوا من
القوانين وبالتالي انما ردا على سؤالك هل
الديمقراطيه افضل يعني في النهايه انا
عندي حد زي بايدن النهارده
اساء التصرف بعد اربع سنوات هيمشي وهيجي
غيره في امل في التغيير انه الناس اللي
اساءت تروح لكن انا لو ما عنديش ديمقراطيه
خالص
ما انا مش هيمشي ابدا يعني هيسيء كل شيء
في اداره البلد وهيظل موجود وكلما طال
الامد واساء السياسات لن يستطيع الخروج
هتتعقد المسائل اكتر فما فيش شك انه لما
يكون في تداول سلطه لما يكون في مسائله
انه افضل من الا تكون هناك مسائله ولا
تداول سلطه
احنا قدامنا اسئله كثيره يا صديقي
من هي الدوله رده فعل الشعوب الاوروبيه
بعد الحرب
هي حوارات نعم ده كده بتسال ده على
البودكاست
مساء الخير استاذ سيد نتمنى حلقه حاضر
مش هقول حاضر بقى
ان شاء الله والله عاوز
السلام عليكم انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك على
حاجه بمناسبه يعني انا مش عاوز
يعني
بفضل الله انا لما بشوف
القناه الجهد المتواضع اللي بودل يعني في
السنوات اللي فاتت احنا بنتكلم على اكثر
من 450 حلقه
كتير منهم تقريبا لم يتكرر كثيرا بمعنى ان
في حلقه عدنا فكرتها بتفاصيل عشان الظروف
انما لما تشوف مثلا
الكلام اللي اتكتب على حرب او الكلام اللي
اتقال على حرب روسيا الاوكرانيه على مدار
حوالي سنه ونصف قبل اندلع الحرب اظن ان
الحمد لله بفضل الله يعني وخفقنا في جهد
كتير بوقائك وبمصادر وبتوثيقه وبالتالي
يعني هي عدد الحلقات مش قليل
والحمد لله الجهد ما كانش فيها قليل وعليه
ده بيخلي يعني اتمنى ان يكون ده عزاء او
اعتذار عن
الموضوعات اللي انا اتمنى اقدمها وما
قدمتهاش ارجو ان تسامحني في ذلك يعني
مساء الخير ما هو رايك سبب سعي الدول
العربيه لاعاده سوريا لابدا اجابه السؤال
كيف ترى في تحركات اجبت نحن نسمع يومين عن
ان مخزونات الليتو من السلاح بدات تنفذ
لماذا لا نسمع هذا عن روسيا هل يعقل ان
المخزونات روسيا او قدراته على تصنيع
الاسلحه اكبر من امريكا والغرب شكرا هو
اولا روسيا بتستعد للحرب مش الغرب ثانيا
الغرب هو اللي بيتكلم روسيا ما بتتكلمش
بالمناسبه روسيا عندها مساحه حريه اكبر من
الدول العربيه لكنها بطبيعتها مختلفه عن
الغرب
مش هم اللي بيطلعوا كل يوم هو يعني كده
ثقافه الغرب كده يعني بيطلع ويتكلم صح مش
دايما بيقولوا الحقيقه انما عندهم شفافيه
اكبر دي ثقافتهم ودي برلمانيتهم ودي
المسائله اللي بنتكلم عليها ودي لها مزايا
كبيره
ولها عيوب فبالتالي الغرب هو اللي بيقول
انا ما عنديش وهو اللي بيقولوا ان الروس
ما عندهمش
عاوزين منك حلقه عن تحليل وجبنا
عوده تحرك الامريكي بقوه لمنطقه العراق
وسوريا والخليج برايك هل ضرب ايران بجديه
هو بيتحركوا علشان في تطورين التطور الاول
انه فعلا برنامج النووي الايراني وده
بيقول لحضرتكم عاوز حلقه وانا كنت بمناسبه
الكلام عن الحلقات انا كنت مجهز حلقه عاوز
اقولها امبارح
انما ظهر لي موضوع التطورات في الاراضي
المحتله عملت حلقه وسجلتها النهارده
وبعدين انا مش راضي عنها ففي الغالب يعني
هقعدها بكره بمناسبه الوقت الكثير اللي
بيا
انما هم بيتحركوا عشان حاجتين الحاجه
الاولانيه انه فعلا البرنامج النووي
الايراني ازمه طالت وتبحث عن حل وهم
بيبحثوا مع الاطراف الاخرى في الدول
العربيه مش بالضروره يكون الحرب بس
بيبحثوا عن حلول
منها انه يخنق الاقتصاد الايراني اكتر
الحاجه التانيه انه في امل هم بيسعوا
املين في اقناع الدول العربيه انها تنضم
اليهم في الحرب على روسيا وبالتالي في
نشاط اكبر بس مش بقوه ولا حاجه هو زار ما
هو زاره اسيا الوسطى يعني اسيا الوسطى بقى
فيها تغيير جوهري خارجيه امريكا لما راح
يزور اسيا الوسطى كذا خستان تركمان
الى اخره يعني خد معه وهي دول واقعه تحت
النفوذ الروسي
والصيني 25 مليون دولار يعني مساعدات تخيل
خمس دول في 25 مليون دولار كل دوله خمسه
مليون دولار
فيعني امريكا ما عندهاش كتير تقدمه يعني
ارجوك ان تشرح هل سيدفع الوضع
الداخلي المتازم في اسرائيل الى مغامره
عسكريه
ممكن
بس مش هتبقى برغبته يعني دي مساله اكبر من
الناس لما بيكون عندهم ازمه داخليه وعاوز
تعمل مغامره بيعملها بشكل محسوب مع دوله
اصغر والانتصار فيها يبدو مضمونا بيتقال
ده مع ايران المساله صعبه
هل ممكن اسال حضرتك ليش السويد عم تدعم
وترعى حزب العمال الكردستاني هي مش كانت
بترى حزب العمال الكردستاني حبك فيه هو
حصل ان عندهم معايير بيقولوا انا عاوز
اكون لاجئ سياسي
بيروح هناك كلاجئ سياسي طبعا انا عارف ان
الاجابه تبدو بريه اكتر من اللازم انما هو
برضو انت بتتكلم على
اخونا
سرفايفر ما انت بتتكلم على السويد
دوله جت في فتره من الفترات وكانت عاوزه
برضو تبقى لها دور وعاوزه يكون لها سياسه
خارجيه
بالمناسبه ده في دول تانيه زي مثلا سويسرا
ما حدش يتوقع ان لها ادوار من تحت لتحت
كده يعني
بتضر مصالحها بان هي تبقى جزء من ملفات
كتيره انما الجزء الظاهر والكبير ان قال
له والله انا عندي انا لاجئ سياسي وانا
مطارد وليس لي وطن وانا حابب استقر في
دوله تضمن لي امنيه بيقول له تعال
حروب حروب الحديثه حروب جماعات صغيره كما
حدث في العراق وسوريا مواجهه واليوم في
حرب روسيا وجماعه فاجنر تقصد يعني اللي هي
الجامعات اللي هي المسلحه موجوده طول
عمرها والامريكان هم يعني
من انتاج الامريكان الفكره في انه بيلجاوا
لها ليه انه الجيوش عليها ضوابط وعليها
انت مثلا عشان تحرك الجيش وتروح مكان معين
احيانا بتحتاج موافقه البرلمان بتاعك او
الكونجرس لكن عشان تحرك جماعه اللي هي او
جيش خاص وتسلحوا يعني انت مش محتاج تاخد
موافقه حد وبغض النظر عن الموافقه الخسائر
في الجيش لها ثمن وتساءل عليها انما جماعه
تخسر زي ما تخسر المهم تحصل على اتعابها
واجرها
الجيش ممكن يتورط في مشاكل تعرضه الى تسيء
لسمعه البلد اللي فيه جرايم ما ينفعش
يعملها لكن اذا كانت حاجه محتاجه او عمل
قادر والجامعات دي عملته ممكن يعني تنفض
ايدك منها وبالتالي لها دور
اذا خسرت الجامعات ديت او قتلت ده مش
اهانه لجيشك بشكل كبير
لو كانت الديمقراطيه نموذج ناجح لماذا دول
مثل امريكا اللاتينيه تغرق في الفساد
والفقر رغم تبنيها للديمقراطيه
انت زعلان قوي من الديمقراطيه اخونا تشاد
يعني انا انا موضوع الديمقراطيه نفس
الاجابه انت انت هتعمل ديمقراطيه يعني
هطبق نظام النظام ده ما بيجيش من فراغ
يعني انت النظام ده لما اجي اطبق مثلا في
بريطانيا بريطانيا نجحت فيها الديمقراطيه
لانه اعلى 300 400 سنه في حاله صراعا
الملك يبقى عنده سلطات وفرنسا يبقى سلطات
مطلقه ولا سلطات نسبيه الكنيسه لها سلطات
مطلقه ولا سلطات نسبيه طيب اصحاب رؤوس
الاموال بيتطوروا على مدار سنين وكل تطور
صاحبه ثورات وحروب اهليه فاستقرت المؤسسات
العمليه مش ان انا اجيب نظام وخلاص انت
هتجيب نظام ديمقراطي تطبقه على بلد اصلا
الابن ما يقدرش يقول كلمته قدام ابوه لانه
انت عندك نظام ابوي السيده بتعامل على
انها مواطن من الدرجه الثانيه رجال الدين
كلمتهم مسموعه اكتر من الشخصيات المنتخبه
ده نظام انا ما بقولش ان ده وحش بقول انه
النظام ليه ظروفه يعني الحرب اليمين
واليسار اللي احنا اتكلمنا عنه كتير جه
منين انت عندك ثوره فرنسيه
طرحت فكره حل الحاكم ان يظل مطلق
الصلاحيات ولا يجب تقييدها سنه كامل انت
بتتكلم
1800 اخر يعني 1700 حاجه وتسعين سبعه
وتسعين وثمانيه وتسعين يعني 1800 كانت من
200 سنه واكثر من 200 وحوالي 230 سنه
بيطرحوا هذه القضيه فانت بتتكلم على دول
خدت مسافه طويله يعني
برايك هل زي ما تم انقاذ الدوله السوريه
هو الدوله السوريه منقذة لكن انت بتتكلم
ان البلد يعني هي خلاص يعني الحرب لكن في
في ملفات ثقيله مش موجوده هيعملوا ايه في
ادلب هتفضل ادلب زي ما هي ادلب مثلا كده
هل هتستقر مناطق الحكم الذاتي موجوده في
القرد برضا من الاتراك والنظام هل الوضع
الاقتصادي في سوريا يفضل وهو تحت حصار
عنيف هل الناس هتفضل عايشه
ب 15 و20 دولار في الشهر او اقل
مصلحتنا كعرب كخروج مصلحتنا كعرب خروج
روسيا منتصره ام بقاء الوضع على ما هو
عليه والله سؤال صعب لان الدول العربيه مش
على قلب رجل واحد يعني الناس المتضررين من
الوجود السوري مثلا في سوريا كلهم راي
مختلف عن بلد زي الجزائر مثلا على
علاقاتها طيبه بروسيا لكن انا في تقديري
انه
الافضل ان لا تخرج روسيا خاسره يعني
[موسيقى]
الدول العربيه يعني عاوز اقول ايه يعني
هي مجموعه من دول كتير قاعده بتشاهد
المشهد ولا حول لها كبير ولا قوه يعني اصل
انت بتتكلم على صرع ديناصورات فانهارده
انت بتحاول تتعايش مع الوضع اللي موجود
احنا تضررنا جدا جدا من الحرب ونتضرر اكتر
لو الحرب طالت يعني
وبعدين عرف كلمه انتصار تنتصر يعني ايه
روسيا ان هي تاخذ اوكرانيا وتتوقف مش
نهايه الكون يعني يعني مش نهايه الكون
بالنسبه حتى للغرب انما تاخذ اوكرانيا
وتبتدي تهدد بولندا وتهدد دول البلطيق او
الدول دي تشعر بالقلق فتهاجم روسيا يعني
مفهوم الانتصار برضو لازم يكون واضح تنتصر
يعني ايه تاخد مثلا شرق اوكرانيا وتسيب
غرب اوكرانيا للاوكران
حاجات كتيره عاوز التفاصيل والتفاصيل هي
اللي تحدد
ايه اللي ممكن يحصل لاوروبا ولينا وللعالم
حمزه من المغرب عليكم السلام هل تعتقد ان
اوروبا بالاخص فرنسا تعرقل نهضه اقتصاديه
في المغرب خوفا من سيناريو يشابه تركيا
يزاحم مصالحها وهل مشكله الصحراء المغربيه
شكل من اشكال تقييد المغرب كل دوله يعني
من غير ما تسقط الحاله الفرنسيه على
المغرب ما فيش دوله لما بتيجي تتعامل مع
دوله تانيه بتتمنى لها الخير والسعاده هي
بتحاول دايما تخليها معتمده عليها وفي
حاجه اليها
وتدعمها فقط بحساب اذا كان هذا الدعم سوف
يصب في مصلحتها زي ما كنت بتكلم على
سنغافوره او بتكلم على فيتنام
فرنسا فرنسا عندها استثمارات شركاتها اخر
التقرير قريته كان حوالي 12 مليار دولار
ده رقم مش قليل بالنسبه لبلد يعني اقتصاده
متوسط او صغير
فرنسا من القوه المتوسطه كدوى يعني على
المستوى العالمي والمغرب دوله متوسطه على
المستوى الاقليمي فتنشر بليار دولار مش
قليل عندها مصالح امنيه عندها مصالح
اقتصاديه وما عندهاش استعداد انه المغرب
تفلت منها يعني فهي يعني
يعني بتقول ان هي هل تعرقلها هي مش
تعرقلها ليه بتحاول ان تخليها تحت
وصاياتها تحاول تخليها تحت نفوذها تحاول
يعني تستبدلها بالغير وهكذا وانا مش يعني
انا حتى هذه اللحظه يجوز انا في حاجه مش
فاهمها انتم بتسالوا كتير عن المغرب
وفرنسا حجم التوتر اللي موجود اللي بيروح
ويجي ده امر معتاد واذا كنت بتتكلم على
الحاله المغربيه تمثل في عدد من الدول
وكملها مثلا اسبانيا
ما هي زعلت برضو الروس في الفتره الاخيره
لما قدمت دبابات لاوكرانيا بس ده حاجات
الدول بتتقبلها امتى تبقى ازمه مشكله
كبيره لما تكون ازمه تناقض ما لوش حل لكن
دي ازمات بتروح وتيجي يعني لو عندك معلومه
تانيه قولي
رده فعل الشعوب الاوروبيه الحرب اظهرت
ادناه
معلش لحظه كده علشان انا بس اسالك تتكرر
اعتقد
عبيده وضع اليمن هل ينقسم ام لا اجاب بن
عبيده الوضع اليمن منقسم عشان لو انت ما
كنتش حاضر من الاول ما بين الحوثيين
مسيطرين على معظم الشمال التاريخي وعلى
مجموعه من القوى اللي مسيطره على اليمن
الجنوبي ودول ممكن ينقسموا على نفسهم اذا
سلموا بسيطره الحوث على الشمال او اذا
هزموه
هل لديك اخبار عن تفكير الصين في دعم
الروس
عبد الله العتيبي ايوه هناك تفكير صيني في
دعم الروس بالاسلحه لكنه حتى الان لم
يتحقق
ماذا حصل بزاله وزير الخارجيه السعودي
للسوريا وهل هذا امر ممكن وهل هذا امر
ممكن وشكرا جزيلا على موضوعيتك الجميله لا
ما اعرفش مدار انا محتاج اسجله عندي وان
شاء الله نتناوله في حلقه تانيه اللي هي
العلاقات السعوديه السوريه
بس عارف الاطار العام لان لسه كنت اقوله
اكثر من مره اثناء الحلقه يعني
هل حلقه ممكن تشرح فيها ما هو ما هو
انضمام ما هو نظام الصرف في تونس يعني كيف
يتم تقويم العمله لانه منذ سنتين منذ سنين
سعر الصرف مهما يحدث من اضطرابات سياسيه
او اجتماعيه سعر الصرف لا يتغير بشكل
ملحوظ معناه ان هو سعر ثابت يعني هم
مثبتين سعر
الدينار
امام العملات الاجنبيه او قدام الدولار
اذا كان لا يتغير ملهاش حل تاني يعني
بس ده معناه انه بيستنفس الاحتياطي كله في
دعم السعر عند سعر معين انا ما اعرفش
المعلومات دي انا بستنتج لما انت بتقول لي
ان سعر الدينار لا يتغير فبقول لك ده
معناه ان هو بجد يعني مثبت امام الدولار
وبجد ده معناه انه المفروض ينزل ما بينزلش
لانه هو بيوفر الدولار عند السعر اللي هو
عاوزه ده بيكون بمساعدات خارجيه باستنزاف
الاحتياطي اللي موجود لاخره صعب انه يستمر
الى الابد يعني
سيد الديمقراطيه لا تصلح في الدول العربيه
كل الاحترام الولايات المتحده لديها قواعد
عسكريه في كل محيط الصين اكيد القوات دي
مش
بتاكل وتاخذ فلوس من امريكا بدون مقابل
وكمان ربنا قال واجعلنا بينهم العداوه
والبغضاء انا ما فهمتش السؤال يا اخونا
ديل التراند القواعد العسكريه في كل محيط
اكيد القوات دي مش بتاكل وتاخذ فلوس من
امريكا بدون مقابل تقصد ان هم يعني
بيستعدوا للصراع مع الصين طب ما هو ده
معلن ده مش سر يعني
السلام عليكم سيد معلش الحاجات بتطير تاني
انت بتخبي الاسئله دي يا ماندو
طب انا جالي اخر سؤال ما هو مصير الدول
المسانده لاسرائيل الدول المسانده
لاسرائيل ده كتير من دول العالم مستند
لاسرائيل قصدك الدوله العربيه بقى
هي الدوله العربيه مش مسانده لاسرائيل
للامانه هي الدول
وجدت انه عندها مشكله تانيه وهي تحديدا
ايران فحبت ان هي تنوع ادواتها واستعانت
باسرائيل انا لا اتمنى هذا بس هقول لك
منطقهم الامر الثاني انه شافه انه الطريق
الى قلب امريكا هي اسرائيل
وكانت الزمان هي ازمه اساسيه او قضيه
مركزيه واحده اللي هي
فلسطين تعدلت القضايا وهذه الدول ضعفت مع
تفتت العالم العربي
وفي جيل من الشباب طلع اصلا ولد واصبح
عنده يعني عشرين سنه ولا حاجه وهو ما لوش
اي علاقه خالص يعني ولد بعد القضايا
الفلسطينيه بسنوات
جيل مختلف يعني على العموم ده السبب انت
بتقول مصيرهم ايه ما فيش مصير ولا حاجه
المساله مرتبطه بان هم
يعني ما بيستثمروش في القضايا الفلسطينيه
اعتبروها يعني للاسف قضيه خاسره
هو ماندو بيلعب
ضيق ليغ اوف ليجنز اليغو فليغ
هو حاجه في حاجه اسمها
انت بتلعب
طب انت بتنكر ليه قول ما فيش مشكله
لازم تريح
لازم تريح باين عليك التعب صحيح استاذ عبد
الله فعلا ربنا يخليك وناخد بنصيحه
الاستاذ عبد الله ونجاوب كمان خمس اسئله
هنختم
يعطيك العافيه يا سيد هل من الممكن حلقه
عن ازمات بريطانيا بشكل مفصل والى اين
بريطانيا ذاهبه في حلقه مفصله ما زالت
قائمه
وكانت كيف اصبح اقتصاد بريطانيا العظمى
يعني
واقع في كل هذه الازمات اكتب بريطانيا على
اقتصاد نعرف على على نعرف الامه مش نعرف
بس وممكن طبعا مع التطورات نعود اليها مره
اخرى
ما هو الحلف الجديد
السعوديه ومع من بما ان الحلف الرباعي تام
ما فيش تحالفات ولا حاجه كلمه حلف كلمه
كبيره انما احنا في حاله عامله زي لعبه
الكراسي الموسيقيه
يعني علاقه بتتوتر مع الامارات شويه
وبعدين تبقى كويسه شويه العلاقات تبقى
قويه مع مصر شويه بتتوتر شويه وهذه طبيعه
الامور تعال شوف علاقه فرنسا بايطاليا
ببريطانيا بالمانيا بالولايات المتحده
بولندا المساله مش قاصره على الدول
العربيه يعني ده امر مش مش غريب
بيستحالفات ما فيش حاجه يعني ما فيش حاجه
دراميه انه تحالف يعني اتفاقيه الدفاع
وهكذا او عدائي يؤدي الى الصراع لا توترات
العاديه يعني
برايك يا مسافه صمود الاقتصاد الروسي ده
انا عملت حلقه كامله عن سبب الصمود
الاقتصاد الروسي ببساطه لانها دوله عندها
اقتصاد قوي جدا لكن الناس بيختصروها في
رقم يعني
غير دقيق ان انا اقول لك ان هي اقتصادها
واحد ونصف تريليون دولار اي بس المعادله
القوه الشرعيه قد اقتصاد المانيا وعدد
سكان روسيا قد ايه احنا بنتكلم على 145
مليون يعني اقل من نصف سكان الولايات
المتحده وفي نفس الوقت
اكبر مساحه في العالم عدد ضخم جدا من
الانهار اراضي زراعيه هائله ثروات ضخمه
على كل المستويات قاعده صناعيه قويه الى
اخره
هل يمكن اعتبار سياسات الحكومه المصريه
الاقتصاديه على انها تضحيه بشعبيه الحكومه
على سبيل الاصلاح
اعتبرها زي ما انت عاوز بس هو في وضع
اقتصادي صعب وفي الاوضاع الاقتصاديه انت
بتاخد اقل بتاخد احسن الخيارات المتاحه
امامك ضحي بقى بشعب الحكومه يضحي باي حاجه
ثانيه هو بياخد القرارات اللي يعتقد ان هي
افضل خيارات من وجهه نظره
السلام عليكم استاذ ممكن نتكلم عن الاحواز
العربي والتطهير العرقي الذي يحصل هناك
ليس لدي معلومات كافيه انا بصراحه بتجيلي
يعني ناس مشكوره بتتواصل معايا ويقول لي
اقدم لك
يعني وثائق وكذا كتر خيره بس ببقى مع
تتابع الاحداث بتبقى في قضايا ضغط عاليه
جدا بتابعها ربما لو في سبب قوي اعيد
النظر فيما يصلني من معلومات واعطيها
اهتمام اكبر يعني
لماذا تصر الامارات على توسيع التعاون
التجاري والسياسي مع اسرائيل رغم انها
تستطيع ان تجد بطائع افضل في دول اخرى ولا
تحتاج اسرائيل لكل الاسباب اللي انا قلتها
اسرائيل دوله بتقدم نفسها على ان انا
مستعد اتعاون معكم امنيا وعندي قدرات
تكنولوجيه واستخباراتيه وانا اهم وسيط لكم
للولايات المتحده وانا عندي تكنولوجيا
قريبه من البيئه الصحراويه اللي انتم
عايشين فيها ثم بيننا خطر مشترك وهو ايران
ثم ليس بيني وبينكم عدوات يعني كل ده يعني
ثم الضغط الامريكي الكبير
ثم التهديد الايراني برده قلنا المصادر
الاحرار بتتابع منها مجريات السياسه
الخارجيه اولا وثانيا اقترح علينا كتب
جديده اعتقد ان احنا ممكن نختم بهذا
السؤال انا يوميا ما اعرفش ده يتوفر لك
لانها ده هو هذا هو عملي فانا بتابع
مجموعه من الدوريات بشكل يومي بس عددها
كبير لان انا بشوف مثلا
انا بشوف
فرن باليسي انا بشوف
انا بشوف مثلا بشوف
[موسيقى]
ده موقع برضو جيد انا بشوف اقانه في عدد
كبير يعني عدد كبير واحيانا بالموضوع مش
يعني في حاجات ببص عليها كل يوم زي
الحاجات اللي بقول لك عليها دي ابص على
العناوين اذا كانت حاجه تهمني
انما في حاجات مش بتابعها كل يوم لكن انا
ببحث عن عنوان مثلا بتكلم على الازمه
السوريه فببحث ممكن الاقي بقى يطلع لي عدد
كبير ونتيجه الخبره بقى اللي هي السنين
الطويله انا عارف ان مثلا توجه
الصحيفه دي كذا ان ده مصداقيات وكذا
فبالخبره فبشوف الكلام ده كله وعاده بجمع
الحاجات دي من لازم يكون اكتر من مصدر
بتاكد من المعلومه وبعدين اذا كانت
وده كتير بعمله بعد ما اجمع المعلومات دي
احاول استعين بمصادر لان انا صحفي فعندي
مصادر انت بتسال بقى على الطريق اللي
بشتغل بها يعني
[موسيقى]